give me the horse noise
hi everyone hello happy holidays guys
holy holiday shirt for you
the couple thousand people who enjoy the
youtube channel we'll see that the rest
of you
prefer not to see us which
lesson message received
you don't like bianca's head what are
you gonna do
i mean oh you know what i wanted to talk
about that uh i
forgot to last week um
i i'm a hoarder yeah we know that
but what i real now wha i was hoarding
things because i just didn't know i just
didn't want to put them in landfill
and um but what i realized is
if you go if you live in la and i'm sure
they have it in every or not every city
but you know the good ones
there is a program where you
there's a there's like a day well in l.a
it's
friday saturday thursday friday saturday
or friday saturday sunday some
combination
okay uh or sometimes it's monday yeah
wednesday
and then the tuesday before um
where you can drop off paint solvent
anything in that family in that like
what the [ __ ] do i do with this
family there's another one for e-waste
which is
chords i'm going to have a big weekend
with that one i got e-waste
20 20. that's eric andre e-waste
and um and so i got rid of paint
i got rid of a ton of [ __ ] and there's a
closet whatever it's a long story but
i'm
i got i opened up the closet do you guys
have two and a half hours
um i emptied out the closet the one main
closet i have i got rid of all the paint
and [ __ ]
that's been in there for 10 years and
then i'm that the one below the
staircase
the people under the stairs no that one
oh we don't have it off
uh it's kind of it's at the anyhow so i
empty that out and now i'm gonna slowly
migrate [ __ ] from the table
into that while getting rid of
chords rid of [ __ ] from the table yeah
i'll get rid of some of it but now i
know i have so many chords
because you know i buy dumb [ __ ] and
every piece of dumb [ __ ] comes with two
two
different chords um two different dumb
chords
on the front of it just says now with
two different dumb chords
so i'll get rid of so it things are
changing
out here at neil brennan inc and
secondly i got a label maker because
what
well what dumber thing can a person get
a thighmaster yes i got a label maker
um
[Music]
should be shorter um still can be
shorter
um i know but i'm saying just get to the
what it is like why make people wait um
i got a label maker and
i got some sticky magnets anyhow i have
a way
that i do my set lists now where it's
but it's on a whiteboard magazine i saw
that pretty great
uh you know you can also just get that
stuff picked up
you don't have to go drop off yeah uh
yes not during kova though okay but
normally i mean it can be for animal
dead animals
if your animal dies they'll do it shout
out to you keith
give me that number make a pizza because
he's been wheezing
keith has been wheezingly can i tell you
something go
the fact that keith doesn't come down
and greet me i'm worried about his
health
he didn't want he went to the steps yeah
but then i was i hear the steps and he
did a
half paw half paw because he's scared of
the steps sometimes
okay for no reason is he's health okay
yeah he just sometimes he gets scared i
made a video saying he's weird you can't
go i was whipped kidding
oh i was like he's kidding he's gonna it
seems like he's in a lot of pain
i'm just gonna let it play out um
there you go whoa there you go um
more wow
four minutes in three o for three
um so things are happening
things are shifting and um
it's pretty exciting where i'm from in
the bay area in
santa clara county they do two days a
year and it's called like a spring
cleaning and
they'll take anything everybody
furniture beds everything so when that
day happens it's like a weekend
oh my god there's so many people it's
like a free garage sale essentially
because people give nice [ __ ] it's not
it's not like
probably social media like hey i
actually have good [ __ ]
i don't know about that but it just
everyone knows about it so there's so
many people like
just rummaging through the streets for
like a week have you
have you dumpstered them i haven't but a
friend of mine
got a whole couch a whole ask a whole
house
couch and it was so uncomfortable i was
like it was antique
so she's like we gotta there's nothing
better than an old couch gentlemen a
couch with history forget it
it's get you know captain tells a story
that's what you want from your couch
um is to tell a story on my couch that i
is the wrong couch for this space
it looks dumpy it yeah
it's low and it's too smushy
and between the clutter and keith what
keith does to the blankets
it looks sad it looks bad divorced and
it was so expensive really yes did you
get it from article
i got it from uh the other one
uh restoration yeah oh wow that's
a premium yeah and i got the discount
and it was still like
oh it's since they they're too expensive
somebody here's a here's a rich person
sorry do we have a rich per this isn't
even trouble in the vip
by the way it to get it dry cleaned
we need a song for you get it dry
cleaned this is called rich people
problems
retrievals to get it dry cleaned cost
for the duvet for like the cover was
seven hundred dollars
wow um to clean i was once complaining
about this
to let's call her porsha de rossi
and i was uh uh which actually sounds
like a fake name
of somebody i was speaking to a friend
of mine portia de ros it's like an
austin powers
and this is my associate oprah um
austin powers so goddamn funny and
people don't understand how funny it is
everyone everybody understands but it's
not even funny
it's he's making fun of antonioni's
[ __ ] blow up he's making fun of [ __ ]
that you've been
whatever like i said how much do you
think
the kid the couch was and porsha goes i
don't know 14 grand
14 grand [ __ ] 14 grand but that's the
world they live in they yeah
they they they pay 14 000 for a cap
never
from my house have
no i was like they're i was like their
scrackly nephew
um i was no i mean
i would say [ __ ] i called ellen the
white steve harvey one time
yeah that's good it's the [ __ ] best
the people don't talk to it like that
anyhow how how's your week been hon
good okay i just don't [ __ ] remember
i just writing you can write it down i
know i'm just i
i just ah you black out i do i really
blank out about what i did it's very
it's weird and i only notice it when you
ask me i'm like [ __ ]
well it's hard to remember what what is
happening because we're not doing
anything so it's just different shapes
covet is so weird different shades of
gray
differ 50 maybe maybe 50.
have you been tied up um
uh hey
don't yell at me speaking of yelling at
you
will you play i think this is a trouble
in the winner's circle
this is a little trouble yeah
[Music]
um tom cruise
i believe expressed all of our feelings
loved it anti-masters loved it
um this wasn't even an anti-mask
situation
but it's we don't know what there's this
thing where there's
people don't want to bother do we know
what the guy was doing
apparently there were two guys unmasked
on the set
looking at a monitor or something um
and he saw them and
[ __ ] flipped here are some of the
highlights here's some of the highlights
we are the gold standard
they're back there in hollywood making
movies right now because of us
because they believe in us and what
we're doing
i'm on the phone with every [ __ ]
studio at night insurance companies
producers
and they're looking at us and using us
to make their movies
we are creating thousands of jobs you
love [ __ ]
by the way that's how you feel yeah when
you're in charge of anything yeah
it's just just like you [ __ ] i love
you yes
it's like you ungrateful [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] trying
yeah that's how
it's a it's a it's a a
completely unsympathetic position
to be tom cruise in any pretty much any
situation
people are going to sign with you
because you're a movie star but the in
the back of their head like [ __ ] guys
got a billion dollars and he
and he's a scientologist yeah so like
he has no cr he's gonna lose a ton of
arguments but
for the sake of
this is what my inner monologue sounds
like not often
like with will like i'll say things like
well you know i pay you
[ __ ] like that uh when you ask for some
you ask for very little
and you get less than that when you're
saying like hey there's a worldwide
pandemic
where we've already been shut down right
his movie had already been shut down
once and we cannot get shut down again
and i'm i'm sure i mean he's a producer
so he's got
a lot of liability and it would people
think it's like
well he should have handled a different
way how about if someone's doing a stunt
without a harness
right because that's what they're doing
they're basically like
potentially putting multiple lives at
risk
right right because they just don't feel
like it and then you're allowed to yell
i guess but even i saw like i will i
don't think that there's this is the way
to handle this like
no please because everybody loses their
temper i get that he lost his number
it's like he shelled out out of his own
pocket
um he put everybody up in a place so
they quarantined
on his dime and then they started but
you know what the funny thing is when i
saw this whole thing the only thing i
could think of and not a lot of people
realize this
most people on cruise are
trump supporting midwesterners or east
coasters or
southerners most of them are white most
of them are older men
and most of them have gotten they don't
have boats and they have
boats and they all have they have speed
boats or whatever motorboats
and they have big pickup trucks they're
all in unions
it is hard to get and they wear shorts
cargo shorts
cargo shorts yeah uh so boots
yeah so it's like you don't really
understand like i
was not surprised about this i wasn't
surprised
i mean i i i did a show last night
and it was like a via satellite it was
like sarah mello does a show that's
um you're like in a video environment
and i'd heard it was good and how'd you
like it safe
i i uh like about four o'clock i was
like i don't want to [ __ ] do this
like i was like i don't wanna there's no
point yeah
in doing this show there's zero point
and
and sarah's like they had they're gonna
do a rapid test when you get there
and i was like okay cool okay
okay and i've heard it's a minimal crew
and i get there
no we are not doing a rapid test we'll
take your temperature
okay but that wasn't the agreement and
then i go in
and there's and there's there's
only four people in the room but it just
is like
there's five you need four yeah why do i
need this man
i haven't been the only time i was
inside with
more than you two was on a on the
gatorade thing
and i and i just was like you're paying
me i
like i'm i have to get hazard pay
because i'm not i don't want and they
test it no yeah and i made them test the
[ __ ] out of me and everybody
repeatedly right and so
the fact that you have this that you
promoted the other day that that like
the video
yeah show yeah um and the fact that
tom cruise has to be in charge of it
that they're
i mean that like he has to keep an eye
on people
is [ __ ] insane and it speaks to
how not how everyone does this [ __ ] with
a wink
um of course it's just like yeah yeah
we're safe yeah
come on come on look at me um would you
do that
again no and and i told melo i was like
there was no i just realized there was
no point in me doing this yeah
and i didn't like the set i don't like a
split second
before i hear if there's a laugh or not
it's like a bunch it was
it was a nightmare it's funny because
i've seen people do the like i'm
standing in a video room but i
just don't for people like this one was
good
and i went i was like this is not good
because i'd be doing jokes and i feel
like
man put that down and it was just
somebody's [ __ ]
open microphone like
it was it just sucked
and it was far it was just like it had
nothing going for it
i sarah mello i love and she does my
santa monica show but
[ __ ] and i'm sure it's fun to watch
better than nothing
but it's not much better than nothing
yeah i'm like no watch i watched your
your honor yeah you know you got netflix
i mean you go on youtube
thanks video so i also think those are
going to go the way to the
the way of the dodo immediately yo
there's there's no benefit to it it's
not
good and you feel weird
standing in a it was just [ __ ] weird
it was like a night it i said it's good
to be here in my nightmare
it felt like a nightmare um so
anyhow tom cruise rest in power king
um no he's do you think this will affect
him i feel like people like affect him
he's already gotten he's already
he beat [ __ ] scientology seriously do
you know what i mean like he beat
that rap he's that necessary a movie
star
that he he can be in a
religion that kidnapped people and the
david miscavige's wife gone yeah she's
somewhere in seoul
shelley we don't know where she is she's
on the sea where she's
um she's no land lover
um but it's also like hollywood's weird
because what's his face i don't like you
mel still love you but you knew um
he said some weird [ __ ] and somehow
still seems to be around
no yeah he's be i mean he's in the minor
he'll never get to the majors but
really he that one always baffles me
like he's he's like he was in daddy too
daddy did whatever [ __ ] daddy's home
too
which i still don't understand because
mckay and farrell produced it and i'm
kind of like what he
so huh and the other mistake he made was
he started
allowing himself to look old in public
um yet none of these are big movies
the beaver was like that was the last
one
he had out uh expendables of those
that's
expendables three um again
yeah so these are he's not getting back
he's not getting he ain't getting back
he ain't he's not gonna do what when he
wants he's not gonna be on the
cover of uh it's direct straight to
video
video on demand um and but the problem
is like
all of the photos of him he just looks
[ __ ] homeless
um like he just allows himself to to
look
he he needs to wear a tuxedo all the
time yeah otherwise he looks
otherwise he just looks like he looks
like what he is which is a
virulent anti-semite and racist
um so uh he looks terrible
yeah you can never let them see you get
older
he looks egyptian here uh
you know what you're never let them see
you look at you
uh that's a that's a truism
i told will smith stop being gray in
public it's like stop
i don't why what benefit do i get from
seeing you great like the thing that was
upside down that uncle phil
[ __ ] yeah it's like [ __ ] so you don't
mind if they get older just don't
i don't need to see that don't remind me
of death no
you hate being reminded bianca
when has anyone ever aged publicly and
you've been like you know what i'm glad
he did that
it's i don't want to see kirk douglas
[ __ ] slurring
just keep it away i don't want to see
johnny carson get fat
just go and disappear and
johnny carson didn't let us see a good
fat those
goddamn paparazzi damn paparazzi's
he would have gotten away with it
and found him on his uh double decker
boat
um wait did whatever so tom cruise
um uh
was in the right about this he shouldn't
kidnap people
and uh but i will still see
i like tom like i've seen every mission
impossible
they're not that great but they're not
bad they're
well they're as good as the uh
negotiator
uh no negotiator it's not as bad as you
think
not a good movie it's good um it's
i mean it's fine no one why no one's
gonna listen to me but i'm saying
uh but what if you get in another what
if you lose another thousand followers
on twitter
saying the negotiator is not good this
racist ass [ __ ]
uh yeah the negotiator is not a good
mother it's so good um
the the impossible making it possible
because unlike the negotiator it it has
a lot of sets
it has a lot of locations location it's
very glamorous
negotiators have a [ __ ] house in in
in
san fernando valley was die hard the
first one
and you know we were the first one is in
nakatomi plaza it's not in a house in no
i know but it's in one location
but it's in floors it's on different
floors
different lighting schemes he's in a
vent at one point
he has to run over glass i remember roof
yeah they [ __ ] maximize it um take it
from a guy who shot a whole movie in a
[ __ ] car dealership and realized
about a week into it like wait a minute
this whole movie in a [ __ ] car
dealership
i'm in trouble um uh
so and it's glamorous
and it's got better actors um
you didn't like kevin spacey the
negotiator no
i could something i sensed something
about him sam's great but
you know sam always does sam and um
and it has a lot uh the mission possible
has a lot of plot twists
yes and the one that jj avens directed i
think the fifth
one no it's like the fifth one uh
is one of the best looking movies of all
time
um it's it's got number three
it's got uh images images
it's got the it had a lens flare in
pretty much every scene
and uh they had that cool sequence
through the
through the propeller thingies um
phil's phil hoffman's phil seymour
hoffman's [ __ ] great in it
uh it had the the bridge scene where he
runs
uh that one is a killer scene fun to
watch
all of their eye candy it's like that
jade
i don't know who the dp was but he they
[ __ ]
killed it the last one was really good
with ving rhames
they're like oh sorry but that's just i
just remember him there was um
it was in london not uh alec baldwin was
in it that's he's the one that i was
like
oh all right alex yeah um ving one time
gave me a hilarious mission impossible
uh monologue where he told me what he
made on everyone
and i asked him uh he did great okay and
that's when he's like
and that's all because of tom brown i i
think i said on here
you know that bing rhames is gonna he's
one of the biggest gossips i've ever met
and you know it's gonna be juicy because
he starts by going
can i tell you something wrong and then
come on the show and then
he and then he drops dime on everyone
and it's [ __ ] great
and it's yes thank you well we're
look we're in reap we're in word
syndicate most mostly stories are
syndicated
um they've all these are real you now
you turn to us for comfort
where i tell we tell you all the old all
the oldies but goodies
do you know i directed rick james yeah
um
so tom cruise i'm we stand with you
and uh and we we
rest in power king i mean i we we i
couldn't have agreed yeah more great and
sometimes
you gotta yell and sometimes justified
sorry sorry i don't think he yelled the
first time
but there was a section where he got a
little scientology about it but
wait what do you say well if you go back
to the monologue because i will deal
with your reason
and if you can't be reasonable and if i
can't deal with your logic you're fired
it's like uh that sounds a little
scientology
to me i'm sure he i'm sure he knows what
that's straight out of
straight out of hubbard that's straight
out of out of
a straight out of netix yeah it's like
if i
your logic and my reasoning like okay
your side ties showing buddy um you're
sea org showing
yeah your sea orgs showing we're shelly
um
anyhow so that's that let's move on will
moving on mitch mcconnell
what'd he do he
basically now republicans have to
announce
where they'll reality is a policy choice
right where they go uh the president
has uh he's the electoral college has
spoken and whatever
so he basically is saying now before
when trump won uh in 2016
they didn't wait until december to
acknowledge it
no one waited until december no one
waited he didn't not one person not one
person yes he didn't wait for the
electoral college to speak and all that
uh so that's their big thing now is that
they
they're just going like i have a policy
shift that i'd like to and i have a
policy paper and it's just
reality like that's their big from the
desk of mitch mcconnell
i mean he did congratulate yeah
three days ago yeah at
way beyond the point when he should have
he basically
acknowledged reality and then liberals
are so feckless that they go like
oh that's good of him could have been to
acknowledge he's like go [ __ ] you
plenty of people said that um so
uh so yeah so and then today
they all got the vaccine or this yeah uh
what's his face
did public like he got it schumer pelosi
and pence and pence got it pence got
like on air poc pelosi and mcconnell
um i just hope that uh mother was in the
room
when pence got it because you don't want
to he can't doesn't he
he doesn't yeah exactly that's funny um
yeah no he did have a male nurse good
for him
um which of course is
whatever we won't get into it um
is mother there mother was probably yeah
mother's right there
second lady um uh
good for mother got a female and father
got a
male um they're from the middle ages
like mother got a female father got a
male
lollipop um so good for them
and good that they um
with the vaccines that's good the
observation i made about
um conspiracy theorists uh
questioned everything except conspiracy
theories did very well on twitter
i yeah i put it up really well it's just
a good point you know get that a boy
bird
um and uh the other thing you could do
is just exclude people
make it like uh you're not allowed to
get it
and then they'll want it um yeah then
they're like why are we getting it
yeah um dave did a joke in the 90s
where it was
already if you wanted because it's so
[ __ ] up
um it basically if you wanted
they could have made the holocaust
work um they could have put black people
and auschwitz
if they put a velvet rope in front of it
oh my god
it's just so it's just like i learned
that also like
if someone that you know plays hard to
get
just go okay we're doing this thing
goodbye and they go oh yeah oh why
didn't you invite me what are you
oh i would have come no you wouldn't
have i haven't
invited you straight up you wouldn't
come so we have to play [ __ ]
reverse psychology with you all the time
and it's exhausting
you know what's funny the republicans
not just their behavior right now
reminds me of
one time my brother and me and my dad we
rented videos and we won
they rented a he-man cartoon i
originated barbies
movie as a sign of you wanted to balance
the house or something
and we were deciding which one to play
first i'm like let's play the barbie one
they're like
nah we're not watching the barbie one
you watch that tomorrow
we're gonna watch the he-man one all
together because we all especially your
dad
dad was like [ __ ] e-man's god so
i threw a fit and i went to my room and
i was like i'll show them
i'm not even gonna watch it and guess
what they did they started watching it
and they were having fun and i could
hear them and i was like is that popcorn
[ __ ] and i just like slunk slunked out
and just
quietly ate popcorn with you you
probably stood for five minutes i did i
was just like
stood like well i'm not gonna sit down
i'm not here for long
no i'm just having very temporary what's
happening right now
that's just what it looks like with the
republicans it's like
i guess he's the president yeah like
yeah
they're going to make it they're going
to make it worse
it's not it's still bad what they're
doing it's pretty bad
yeah because they're not because i was
seven
and now there's a thing where uh
i was going to say verizon uh pfizer
yesterday
verizon uh was
said yesterday that they just uh a bunch
of the vaccine hasn't been picked up
wow
um and no one they just haven't uh
they just forgot they they uh
they just forgot they just some of it
hasn't been
um millions of vaccine doses already but
states
say shipments work like there's already
[ __ ] miscommunication i mean did you
think look how the no well
america cannot the
founding the it's we
we were founded on nonsense we came here
and natives were like what are you doing
here and we were like
uh we're looking for india and they were
like
this is not india and we were like fake
news yeah
this is india your indians get used to
it and it's the same
[ __ ] thing over nope that's not what
happened
here's what the reality is you're indian
you're indian get used to it lock em up
uh and so that's just a con it's just
the same [ __ ]
there's a good book that i read called
fantasyland where it's
it was even before that it was around
the same
once they even calling them explorers
they're it's insane they're they're
breaking and entering people they're not
even explorers they're [ __ ] b and e
guys i don't even they're like the b and
e boys it's not
they're it's the columbus and all now
i'm not saying we they're wrong i
said this on the podcast but that that
we have to there's nothing we can do now
like that's just what happened we stole
the land and we're going to live on and
we're going to enjoy it
uh but they're being eight boys and
there's just call them anything else
it's just a
it's wrong it's just fact it's it's
incorrect
and then i think they're gonna come off
the six hundred dollars
it's gonna go down three is it down to
three
what the one they're talking about right
now that the um
300 a week federal unemployment but
the [ __ ] up thing is that they're
funneling the
a lot of people just got a 1200 check
whereas if you were on unemployment
they're using unemployment to
give uh stimulus money that i think
everybody should be entitled to
thank you especially you neil my
uh
um or like let's say if you're under a
certain you make under a certain amount
of money because let me tell you
something that six hundred dollars a
week
was you know what i mighty
like is that people called it um trump
check
i don't like like my one i've heard my
brother call it that
like i got my trump check it just feels
like don't make this
kitchen don't give him it's like the
obama phone it's like they don't [ __ ]
bomb a phone there was there was a
alexander pelosi did a thing on hp i
think it was on marsha where it was
a bunch of um people on welfare going
like i got my obama phone it was like a
phone
like a phone service that you would get
that was whatever
do you not like obamacare i don't no i
don't like when they make it
i don't i mean it's the obamacare is a
stupid thing to call it i don't
well i think it came from republicans
saying obamacare and they were like yeah
okay whatever i mean yes it's never
positive right in the trump check one it
felt
positive like this is it was like more
in line with what he was about like i'm
gonna give you money and i'm gonna put
my name on that
and all that it's just some [ __ ] but
um
i don't i don't like it it i don't i
don't know i just don't like
the the the
it feels like obama phone felt racist
and chump checks trump check feels false
uh it feels falsely
populist it's like you're not for these
people you didn't i mean there's
where you said like i don't want to
shake their hands these people are
disgusting
um which is of course he thinks that of
course he thinks
there was another thing i heard that he
said
where where i was watching something
where he didn't think that
russia he said putin said
uh where he goes well i just asked putin
he said he didn't do it i don't know why
they would do it
like there's so many [ __ ] things he
did yeah to prove my point
from last week of no one remembers [ __ ]
no
it was in helsinki and then he says then
when people call him like so you're
saying
our intelligence like you know people
took him to town he's like
i mistakenly yes should i say
he shouldn't have done wouldn't have
done it it's like
i watched it again last night there were
a bunch of butts it was all
he meant what he said of course he did
yeah
i honestly can't even believe some of
the um
excuses we've just accepted and been
like whatever
what's such a low bar that it's like
okay i don't know
what are you gonna do i mean that's the
the rock said some dumb [ __ ]
in the new york times or something where
he basically
heard he's [ __ ] on him yeah [ __ ] him
um
what's he ever done for us um he's the
ep
other than his give us our
um he said something about
the fact that they shouldn't have
bothered with the impeachment
because they weren't gonna convict him
but it's like dude you gotta
you can't let a guy [ __ ] do illegal
[ __ ] right
and i also think the impeachment
of course it contributed to him not
getting to to him
getting voted out and he get it's just
he also
like tarnishing him in ways that he
perceives is unfair is
i think it does do something if you're
gonna be scrappy with him
and play with him and the way he does
like not have you if you have a bad
child
you can't just go bad apple you still
gotta
[ __ ] put lock and ground him even
though he's gonna burn the house down
yeah you still gotta ground them and
then hope and then
make sure that the burn is you can put
the burn
the burning out like there's nothing you
can use just the bad
he's problem shots he's like those he's
like those uh you adopt a kid from
ukraine yes and they're
insane insane biting you and you gotta
sally jessica
there was a we did a sketch one time
that we cut called uh
it was it was a very bad idea for a
sketch
wasn't it on the i think it might it was
sally sally jesse yeah
and there was a boo it was mandela
instructor
it's such a bad sketch i mean it's like
and i did the meanest thing what which
is
there was uh all the kids wore t-shirts
that said mandela's boot camp
and i remember and this goes my fat
phobia is old and deep
i remember when i went to camp it when i
was like 10
that if that they had t-shirts for
people and if you were too
fat they didn't have them in your size
so your t-shirt was just blank
so i did that in the mandela sketch
where the skinny kids got the right
t-shirts and the fat kid
got a blank one wow cause cause
i am a deep rooted
dick oh my god damn now i'm gonna go
back and watch i'm like
i have in fact i believe i have a
mandela's boot camp t-shirt
upstairs for for any day thank you
there's one of each now russian hack
this was not good yaakov smirnoff no
my mom
[Music]
here's the thing that i the thought that
i had that they don't that they're not
bringing up
i my bet is america has
has hacked every single country on earth
to the same
depth that's right russia yes
and well they apparently someone in the
private sector realized that they were
getting hacked
like it was because it's not only the
government it's like 400 of
425 fortune 500 companies oh no i just
mean
if you have done that kind of dirt in a
lot of countries
you know well yeah so now it's that
thing where
this is it's a it's a it's a mutually
assured destruction
right it's the it's we're all if we're
all hacking each other
it's it's there's nothing
if russia does something to us we'll
just
[ __ ] knock out like if they knock out
our thing well not it's just
we all kn it's it's just like a [ __ ]
spider-man like most things in life now
it's the spider-man name
brody's pointing at each other and uh
and
i don't i mean i'm not china
i just assume it'll it hurts copyrights
obviously it hurts like in
intellectual property but i don't think
that
russia is gonna take out our electrical
grid i don't think russia's gonna [ __ ]
with our nukes i don't think russia you
i i think that they realize that there's
gonna be
that if you play it out it's like then
what it all it's all bad
right so what i say is help yourself
russia
help yourself and uh just leave the turn
out the light on the way i mean i
honestly it's what are they gonna do
also i feel like we since the patriot
act i'm
i'm so numb to the fact that we're such
a surveillance state like we
there's no real privacy no so
i mean that's the the great irony of all
the vaccine thing it's like
it's we talk about it here it's like
bill gates doesn't want to
bill gates is already tracking you it's
like what
they're tracking you the technology that
there's technology that can literally
just follow you yeah to and from home i
mean maybe not in venice
google get google google maps it's i
mean it's
yeah china from the second year there
you're covered
on video i was looking up something i
was like [ __ ] i gotta find this website
and i couldn't
remember how i got there and i kind of
remembered what i googled
so i went into this weird tab in my
google history
and i goo and i call it google history
go ahead yeah but it wasn't
it was a different google history tab
and it took me to a place where it was
like
it brought me to everything i've ever
googled
since 2004. like being on ayahuasca
i was like i went back to slavery and um
i'm a slave and i went and it just
showed me
anything i googled that had that key
word in it
and it scared me i mean i it didn't
surprise me
but to see that everything everything
i've ever thought you know what's a
weird one
that is is very uh that i deleted it
that's like deleted that i'm like
everywhere you've ever gone through
every yeah every single thing you've
never ever do autofill
bring up an address that you haven't
learned phone number where you like it's
like
it's like a phone number and it's five
numbers it's so old you're like what
five nine
we've moved on yeah exactly it's so old
with one number
leslie's so old she got warmer numbers
um
um the yeah they they
i somebody d somebody on instagram dm me
and said that from listening
to the podcast they got an
ayahuasca retreat
uh message and they've never googled
[ __ ] it like that where i was that
happened to me
yesterday where i was talking about
something and then it's like
isn't that a phenomenon though there's
some like obviously there's third party
vader mine off
vada um no there's they sell your
third-party obviously
stuff like that so that's fine but like
we still get searches for those hideous
sandals that you hate
oh that's you know what i got that today
i was wondering basic [ __ ] sandals yeah
i love it um
so that's explainable but there is [ __ ]
i forgot there's a name
for because everyone's like they're
listening to us well they
are but what's gonna happen is they're
gonna say it was an accident
of course it's just what they do it's
just what
it's there it's the system they run like
oh there's
one person a guy he was weird he was
from the ukraine he used to bite us
and and he's trouble but he's gone now
yeah but he's gone now and it they'll
just act like it's isolated but
it'll it's it's their it's their this
policy okay so the thing i read
maybe i'm wrong here but from what i
remember it's not
that they're actively listening to you
even though they are that doesn't always
uh connect to their third-party ads it's
that
they have such a tight algorithm on
everybody
that they know they know they not like
in your head but they
if they clicked on the pod you know
through
something and then there's keywords in
the pot like they
yeah the algorithms are so well yeah we
have we have a popular video about
ayahuasca
yeah so it just comes to it's just like
by association and then you start being
like they're listening to me they're not
necessarily listening to you how how it
seems
it's just that algorithms go so deep
they have just so many
data points on us yeah that feels like
magic
yeah uh it's not magic black magic
like [ __ ] i have a joke about this but
they're just to me they're just late
like who's like we would have
done ben had already bought them sandals
so i'm still getting ads for it it's
like google i if i was going to get
those gross [ __ ] sandals
i googled it a month ago it was a while
ago like
at least a month ago so yeah no they
don't they
just they don't fall off they're they're
like corny but they're just like a corny
[ __ ] like
you guys still we all still doing it's
i have a joke about it you'll see it and
on netflix special if i'm ever allowed
to shoot it
no um this may not pertain to you but
james harden
bearded guy bearded guy um
he uh good or bad
he wants he's demanding a trade
oh even though he
he's a weird guy how does that generally
go when
if they demand okay it [ __ ] once you
demand the trade
other teams it it [ __ ] it's
you [ __ ] the team you're on
he says i want out of houston okay so
houston goes to trade them
and everyone that's trading with houston
goes well you got a thing
you're [ __ ] because i don't have to
offer you
as much as i would normally because i
know this guy wants out
so it's just a dick move across the
board now
one of the reasons that it gets floated
is because the owner of the rockets is
super
conservative and he didn't want to play
it for him whatever okay
yes but they're all pretty conservative
i know they're all billionaires find me
one that's like you don't become a
billionaire doing the right thing
um looks like the guy on the he looks
like he's like
he looks like uh he looks like a cross
between paul ryzer
and uh ed o'neill from uh
ed o'neill he looks like every guy in in
chicago
at a bar um so
who's going to get around for the table
um so so
so yeah so i don't know where these guys
are going to find these happier times
they used to be friends
yeah i guess he didn't know he donated
to trump
yeah oh there they are at the game well
that's just them him bum rushing them
and then pretending to
have to but they have if a guy comes up
to a baseball game you got to talk to
him he can't be like what get the [ __ ]
out of here
um and i think he donated to trump like
this past summer but if you look and i
didn't realize
uh after i looked after i realized a lot
of game show hoster
conservatives it's really sad it's like
alex rebeck no
was he conservative he donated to trump
i think and some like local conservative
whatever
uh but yeah a lot like home depot
i mean there's just so many huge
companies
that i think it's just like guys in the
rest of the world
human rights they don't they don't they
want
lower taxes less regulation yeah they
just want
republican [ __ ] it's they they think
that they succeeded because
of republican values but whatever it's
it's
i think it's a misperception but yeah um
yeah of course any rich person is a
[ __ ] republican
it's weird if you're not i commend rich
liberals you're welcome
thank you i think it's very nice because
you know i don't know if everybody
i don't got to be here you really don't
thank you i don't got to be here
blessed us you guys you bless us um yeah
i
but also i don't i i'm one of the few
people who like
says that seems like enough money like i
don't know how much more could i need
where they're like there is no right
yeah
there sometimes i'll look at houses
right
and i'll think i should [ __ ] buy a
house like that
the pool and the wine cellar just a
bunch of [ __ ] you don't need
and then i'm like yeah but then i'll
have to live for
i'll work for the house yeah i will
literally just have to do [ __ ] to
maintain the house
and i don't want to i don't want to do
that i want to be a bad boy
like god intent and ted tended boyd too
um so james harden uh
is so from a basketball person do you
think that's that's completely no i'm
kidding um
um do you think that's a good move or is
it seen as like
whiney i think they're like i don't
i think you kind of have to do right by
the team
even if you don't like the owner meaning
tell him you want to trade
like don't act like you want to trade
just play your
play your tits i mean he creates the
[ __ ]
he really he's an amazing player what is
he good at the jumping
scoring he just scores like he doesn't
even play defense
does he do the far away like uh he does
anything
you could he can do what fate he can get
he can do he can get to the basket
and he can get his own shot he can get
you off the door he'd just get you a
million ways
you know steph curry's always like yeah
he's just drunk he has jumpers
and he's very he's better at getting to
the hoop than
k.d or steph steph stephen
um so i just think it's
it's and also these guys him and kyrie
irving they
kind they kind of lose your mind after a
while yeah it's
the hollywood thing but
almost worse because you don't
people will stop going to see your
movies if you're a big enough dick
there's nothing i just want him to do
the thing i don't care what he
how he behaves so there's really no um
governor on his behavior so they can act
kind of however they want so even if
there's a villain character
you don't mind as long as he plays i
don't yeah i don't
lebron was a villain when he went to
miami and i didn't didn't hurt his
ratings
um it but he probably lost like an
endorsement or two but he didn't
really lose any he didn't really lose
[ __ ] because he was [ __ ]
he's still synonymous with excellence
so if you're synonymous with excellence
you have more leeway to be
yeah he get but um james harden's doing
this weird [ __ ] where he gave
little baby the rapper a little baby or
duh baby
little baby because i had the same
thought of course i went there
um of course it's a goddamn uh maternity
ward in hip-hop right now
um with all the littles and the babies
um
and um there's there's
the little baby you want a little baby
you won't dead you're waiting
little baby james harden he gave him a
richard millie
uh watch and a prada bag and then gave
him
300 gave him like a hundred grand
in cash which they call a honey bun
which is one of the saddest things i've
ever heard
found by a honey bun which is like for a
hundred thousand dollars in cash uh
honey bun um
i don't like honey he just gave it to
him but why
i don't know that's where it's like
you're probably out of your mind
yeah that's weird like you're a very
weird guy also little babies
not broke of course not well not yet
no no give it a couple years he will be
he'll get there he'll get there
yeah um um whenever i see
how rich is that guy do you think james
harden has a lot of money
yeah yeah he's got he makes i just made
224 million dollars
200 in basketball yeah 224 million yes
see how much blake our cub correspondent
has made
call call blake that'd be so rude call
of and ask him his networth
i mean they kind of can't lie he can't
tell us what he's made
he would tell it'd just be a little rude
uh 226 million dollars
blake yeah um
has he been playing longer than james
harden though same same amount
same they got drafted i think the same
thing lucky human beings
on earth i know it's because if there
was 20 years ago they would have made
30. yeah what's up with the contracts in
basketball
that seems astronomical uh they get
half of the door oh like half up front
no they get half of the the door 51
of the profit goes to the players that's
nice well yes compared to football
oh i mean slavery's nice compared to
football
um because slavery though you didn't get
concussions yeah you didn't get cte
um so yeah so it's
better and they have a strong labor
union
and it's good the woman in charge of the
nba players association is a
cool lady black lady named michelle
something
[Music]
michelle roberts robert that is correct
michelle yeah
um she has a natural she doesn't she's
got
she keeps a natural nice short natural
okay but you know
it's a it's a she's a revolutionary but
she doesn't go on and on about it you
know what i mean
um oh speaking of basketball i mean this
is a
this whole episode is trouble in the
winner's circle yeah
yeah yes we deserved it we gotta
we have to renew it uh
vanessa bryant is suing her mom
no mom mom suing her her vanetta yes
vanessa bryant's mom is suing her
because she said kobe would take care of
her
and vanessa bryant
is uh uh
some people were residing with vanessa
bryant
and it's like ladies with vanessa bryant
that's the right thing why would you
side with her
why wouldn't you why would you save them
because she's got 200 million dollars
the kobe said i'll and she won't take
care of her mom
no did you read the whole situation no i
didn't read the whole situation
what is it that's not the situation it's
that her mom
uh is so her her mom basically
has always been taken care of by them
for the last like 20 something years
whatever
and um then i think there was like some
money issue
there was some issue and they were she
was looking for a new house for her mom
while she was looking for a new property
for her mom her mom started going to the
tabloids and saying she's gonna kick me
out of my house
she's not gonna take care of me and then
she started bringing it to the press
that's when she was like all right
mom shut the [ __ ] up still kept looking
for a house
so they tried to move past that but
every time the mom
demanded like no i demand
five million dollars a more like a
mercedes we could have talked to chris
about
who chris a rock it's not it's
meaning the mom is uh the mom is
literally like hey i'll take care of you
but it's like no no no
i want five million dollars i want a
mercedes-benz
suv her mom's trying to get a divorce
basically so the thing is and then
vanessa bryant's like my mom has been
collecting alimony per month
since 2004 from her ex-husband yeah and
we took care of her for the last 20
years
yeah so out of our generosity
not because we had to because she's
financially fine mm-hmm
because she gets alimony i guess that's
from what i read and then her mom
and she was married to james worthy like
her great james webb don't know who she
was
no okay okay i just thought it'd be a
small war one of them small world things
so her mom now is suing her because she
said
i was their personal assistant and i
babysat vanessa brian's like you were
never in our business affairs we got you
in a gated community in newport
and she's like i hadn't had a kid
between my last kids and then my new kid
was 10 years
and my and her kids are all in sports
from day to night and she's like
my mom's not babysitting anyone in the
last 10 years and the first time
she had her she had a kid in 2016 there
was like a 10 year gap
so she was like i don't know what she's
talking about she didn't babysit and we
wouldn't i would have my mom doing my
all of our business affairs which makes
sense to me because it seems like
a lot of business affairs i don't know
if you just trust your mom who isn't
i think the first person you go to is
your teresa is your
is your uh mother-in-law if you're kobe
bryant i think the first person to ask
about your business affairs
so she's like you didn't babysit anybody
you haven't babysat them there's a
10-year period reading babies at them
because they were in school full-time
and tons of extracurricular
activities outside of it here and there
like a grandmother
you have but now she's asking for 95
dollars
a day uh 95 an hour that's 12-hour days
for the last year it's 18 years just
give her the [ __ ] money
don't go to the press and you you know
what i don't you wouldn't
oh no no i wouldn't be playing i would
have no part of this you would
meaning i wouldn't i i'm sorry
that's a hostage situation in you it's a
it's it's a divorce it's a
alimony situation but i mean do you
remember when blake had his thing of
course i do
yeah like yeah we don't talk about but
it's it's it's
but that is a different way rock could
talk about this
ad nauseam actual divorce no yeah
what yes but also
i saw two uh black celebrities talking
one time
and if you can believe this phenomenon
because i don't want to out either
and one of them was like yeah my mom's
not talking to me because i wouldn't
get her a certain kind of car
and uh and the other one goes like
you're 40 and your mom just stopped
talking to you
like it just it's uh that's funny it's a
it's a meaning about like fame success
money
um and they
there's a my lawyer
uh a black proud black woman uh-oh
referred to
chappelle show as a catastrophic success
yay which is a such a great [ __ ] term
and i don't know if it's her coinage
but that's what happens it's like this
is a catastrophic
success for who well just kobe
vanessa the not even the death and the
no no
your life gets so great it's the thing i
say about christmas like with a pile of
fries
just give people some [ __ ] fries um
but it is it is a
catastrophe in some regards there are
parts of my life
family wat that are a catastrophe for
sure and i understand
it's entirely due to
uh being successful and what
that how that makes the people around
you feel right but
if one of your siblings if one of them
sued i'm going we're going to the mats
yeah it's it's you're not gonna yeah you
gotta get petty to me it's like if
someone took care of you
for 20 years it everything seemed like
she
vanessa had all comey had weird [ __ ]
with his parents too
like and his sisters yeah like he they
were gonna sell his [ __ ]
at one point seemed like they had every
intention she had every intention of
continuing to take care of her mom maybe
moving some i it just seems like oh
things are different now you know when
somebody else takes over you get a new
boss or a new manager or something
and they're just changing [ __ ] you don't
like yeah and
i'm gonna make a stink and that's just
kind of what it seemed like because it
doesn't seem like she would put her mom
out
after housing her for 20 years yeah so
she's just coming back with being like
well i
i took care of the kids and that didn't
mean it just seems grasping for sure she
wasn't with
nobody was with with him shooting at the
gym
that's my point speaking of undeserved
money mackenzie bezos
talk about fry's friends talking about a
lot of fries that you didn't
i mean i guess she worked the books for
the first three years so yeah
yeah you deserve 90 billion dollars uh
but
mackenzie bezos is
being [ __ ] cool about it super cool
yes super cool uh she's worth 57 billion
uh after giving [ __ ] away yes uh no it's
probably before because she only gave
four away
five she gave four point eight four
point i don't know i see four point two
and four
um so um
while i think uh alimony
and split
assets is obscene absurd
and you call it great oh i didn't i said
crazy
oh you said great sorry i only heard
great i heard what i wanted to hear
um uh yeah
she she bezos himself
would never do this no so this is a
truly like a robin hood situation where
where she robbed the robbed the rich and
is given
truly rob the rich and is truly giving
it to the
poor and the here's the thing that she's
doing that's interesting
uh because i a friend of mine work was
in advertising
found it depressing so went into the
nonprofit sector
and found that more depressing than
advertising which is hilarious so funny
um a lot of times what happened is
happens is it's not the theory of change
uh ammo look up theory of change
sir yes sir uh
rich people come with
their it's like well i know
they'll give money to uh richard will
give money to
a charity of some kind right and but
with the money comes
the string of now you have to get the
outcomes that i want
and you have to do things that i
you have to basically implement my ideas
for your charity that you guys are an
expert you guys are experts on
and but somehow i think i'm an expert
because how do
would i be right could i be a
billionaire without being an expert can
you explain this
yeah exactly um it's late arriving
instant expert which i think we have a
song for and we never use
now you listen here
[Music]
late arriving instant expert now you
listen here
um so theory of change is a specific
type of methodology for planning
participating and evaluating that is
used
in companies philanthropy not-for-profit
and government sectors to promote social
change
theory of change uh defines long-term
goals and then maps backward to identify
necessary preconditions
i i'm kind of wrong about what the
theory but it's this thing where
rich people dictate it's like the golden
rule whoever has the gold it makes the
rules
and mackenzie bezos is just going
take the money and do it what you want
now
the risk is they misuse the money and
they get a bunch of jackets and [ __ ]
um this is a joke that i
wish we'd done and half baked um
[Music]
that dave pitched um
when there's a point in half-baked where
they're they're making money and they
keep
they all buy a dumb thing and
dave wan and dave has to go like the
[ __ ] are you guys doing like scarves you
can't buy a [ __ ] dog and whatever
but joe was like i should do the whole
scene in a fur coat and never mention it
which is so [ __ ] funny and i so
regret not doing it
it's a lot it would have been like
tonally it would have been wrong
but at that point the tone is so dumb
anyway we should have just done it
i thought that there was a tone i don't
want to violate the tone of this [ __ ]
weed movie
um uh anyhow it's so [ __ ] funny but
that's what you don't want
to get and then they they do with it
whatever but that's the risk you take
when you [ __ ] give money away so you
can't
dictate unless you whatever
uh most of the time if you give it like
she's giving to historical black
colleges and
yeah it's like whatever
i don't know
it's sometimes i think about
uh whether
it's like if i just like i was giving my
maid
my cleaning lady money she's a maid um i
was giving my cleaning lady money
during the pandemic right and she wasn't
working yeah
and giving her like good double what i
don't know how i came to the
i know he talked about how you were uh
but um but it's like i don't know man
what she
she needs the [ __ ] money you don't
really need the money so like well
i'm gonna get she's not she's not
[ __ ] buying
boots right she's just living a small
immigrant life yeah and if so i think
most people that you can give money to
are worthy of your money even if it's
like
people play god though with money i mean
they really like i i when i worked at
whole foods when i was young
i think i told you this before but there
if you brought in your own bag back then
you got five cents off your bill
um or you could donate your five cents
and i worked at one in a very rich area
and they
those [ __ ] are like well what
are the what are the um
what are the charities and it was like
inner inner city kids to science camp
inner city kids to arts
camp or like inner city kids to some
other
music camp they'd be like let me just
say no i i actually give a lot already
yeah and like so take it off the bill
yeah i'm like okay
i would never take it off the bill i
would always just do it on my own like
no you're doing the only people i won't
give to is the
uh like the american heart or lung
association
because if you look at their you go on
charity navigator it's not sponsorships
it's salary it's how much of the money
goes to the cause
they're [ __ ] over 50 overhead which
is like
[ __ ] you guys that's why i don't donate
my clothes to
goodwill because they utilize this
[ __ ] federal loophole for non-profits
where they pay people literally i
i saw a list of the um salaries
all over the map of under a dollar an
hour
11 cents an hour this one lady was blind
she's like i can only afford to go to
work
and go home because what i make a day is
how much it cost me to take the bus this
is their employees
this is the low-level employees at in
the shops
if you're disabled they can pay you they
don't have to pay you
according to any federal right so
they interviewed this i'm a republican
they interviewed the ceo
and he makes nine million dollars a year
i'm like you're paying people eleven
yeah if you go on charity navigator and
uh okay jerry knight
well good give well sorry and they
you can see the breakdown i mean the
disappointing thing about charity
navigator is
the the most effective charities
or you know like the most like direct is
like uh
is are mosquito nets that are
anti-malaria they're like they couldn't
be less sexy
like i gave nets what do you give this
year i
gave a bunch of money and they bought
nets uh
bug assaults and then there's also um
the ten best charity oh that's
everybody's heard of chair to go to
ten total house go to ten
uh top one um so it's like
united methodist committee on relief of
global ministry at child's hope
international
abandoned children's finances these are
yeah they're all very sad
it turns out people that need money are
usually pretty for sad reason
actually it's hunger whatever they're
not they're not all very sexy no they're
not
none of them are sexy i mean like be
honest like they're it's just
i don't i don't know why we're saying
that other than like history black
college you can tell this story
of the person that you're helping
whereas a lot of it's like
it's a net that is against malaria
[ __ ] it's there's no right narrative in
like that one
fly would have gotten in it was [ __ ]
it stinks
um anyhow no but it's good it's just
it's good
i like i like it yeah uh good for you
rest in rest in power queen mackenzie
um this is baby bust
what's going on here everybody thought
there was gonna be a baby boom because
of the pandemic
nah what bust
are you sure positive look it up i feel
like people are [ __ ]
google baby bust thank you buddy
2020 triggered a baby bust and that will
have lasting impacts
there you go early in the pandemic there
were jokes about quarantines prompting a
baby boom but roughly nine months since
coven 19 triggered a national emergency
of the u.s experts are reporting a baby
bust
i don't know why i'm saying it like i
knew it like what did i tell you
uh nationwide a thursday brookings
institute report projects around 300
000 fewer births next year google trends
showed significant decreases in sex and
pregnancy-related searches
and in a report published wednesday
modern fertility found that about 30
of people with ovaries are changing
their family plans
with most deciding to delay conception
i like people with ovaries do you
because i it made me a little crazy
because i was like
what i feel like this is some gender
[ __ ] of course this is
that's why it's funny to me they explain
it later people
go to
people with ovaries that's gonna that's
literally like
you have to check a box yes people with
over uh
keep going down well um in a survey
about thirty percent of nearly uh
four thousand people with ovaries thanks
uh stuck in it so
you know you're being a real that they
were worth i know uh that they were
changing their fertility family planning
timelines respondents identified as
female
99 or gender non-conforming non-binary
genderqueer one person whoa whoa i mean
i i was i'm all for it's
hilarious i know but it's so
it's just so [ __ ] unnecessary and
egotistical on their part like
no change it change it
i change why can't you father [ __ ]
we've got
everything set up for these two things
just figure it out
but again i'll get canceled if i say
that um
uh that was a character i was doing
called republican neil
um that was that's a character yeah
republican neil who doesn't who just
wants the
the these sounds like trans neil tri
well i'm transphobic
transphobic because i'm republican okay
republican is transphobic and he
and he loves that handicapped people
make 11 cents an hour i would like to
see if we can get it down to 10
by the second quarter next year that's
republican daily thinks in
quarterly intervals everything's about
the dollar
um the other thing in this article that
was interesting is
there were less people born in 2018
as well so that meaning more like the
fertility rates
been gone we're making fewer people i
wonder if the
news this stressful news helps or hurts
of course it helps because they they
it well whatever it makes people have
less kids whatever you decide
because it feels just ah
it's not working why would you bring
someone here
it's another one of my amazing jokes why
would you bring
someone no you do it for climate change
i do it for climate change
uh division and um
overcrowding which and that was before
covets
i've added oddly enough myth mythbusters
we don't have an overcrowding
issue what do you mean
meaning there's plenty of space
uh yeah if you are happy to burn the
forest down
no it's just like there's a lot of uh s
capital cities even that just have like
most of the population is in
sf la new york oh you're talking about
america or the world
um i guess let's see
i'm trying to think i mean most people
gather in certain states i don't think
that there's a surplus of space on earth
i don't
meaning we can always use more
and anything we can keep empty becomes
forest which is good for the earth
so let's stop wrong
but i'm not sure but i i just i don't
know
but what do you what's the i the
parameters i think of what we would
disagree on okay
meaning of course i mean is it
is everywhere bangladesh no i'm not
saying i'm talking about habitable space
that people but people just end up
gathering
i'm talking about habitable space in an
environmental context
like just [ __ ] enough because then
you need more people then you need more
cows than you it's just there's too many
people
whether everyone would live in tokyo
like conditions
is another that's a whole other argument
but i'm saying
there's no upside to all these people
trust me
okay there's zero upside and you take
that to the bank
that's how i'm gonna end every segment
okay and i say that as
a person with testicles is it what is a
person with a man would be a person
no because you can be a man and not have
testicles a person
not a good man over his intestines there
you go
we go i'm a person with testes
and you're testy sue me i'm a person
with testis
what can i say what can i say beyonce
um oh this is a useless observation
that i've had yeah what is this i'll
tell you what it is
[Music]
there yeah well i know he can't win he
cut off the beginning but the beginning
is the most part
the beginning should be the whole yeah
this is the galaxy
um so it's got a little something for
you
perfect that's it
[Music]
thank you [ __ ] do like a
uh ten frame dissolve
fade out yeah exactly where we said i'm
like a guy who's editing
jingle quincy jones i really am in that
i
in that i accept i well quincy didn't
write any songs quincy didn't write in
michael jackson's songs
he did write the stanford son theme wow
really in 45 minutes apparently high on
opium
what i heard um
um all right you ever
you'll know what i'm saying once i start
saying it okay
there is a type of person who
when you're talking will do a little
and i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing where it's like did you
hear this already what i i people do it
all the time like i was a younger
kid thing i would
venture that 1 in 15 people does it
that you'll and that yeah
like some they it's this weird thing of
like are you channeling what the [ __ ]
are you doing are you on
are you on are you a spirit padre i
think
when people do it the most is when
you're telling them like an anecdotal
story or really something really funny
and they're anticipating
people do it a lot then so that might
happen to you more
because people really do get so into it
i don't still don't know what they're
doing
they're i'm not like it's not like a
leaning forward like no
no it's just like uh anticipating the
what you're about to say but i've had
people do it when i've been giving them
directions it's
[ __ ] weird okay i don't know
it's a [ __ ] weird it's it's a useful
observation have you seen it well you
know what i'm talking about
yeah and i don't know what they're doing
do you does it bother you
deeply know it uh it it
i don't i just don't know what they're
doing because a lot of times they don't
know they're doing it no they don't know
they're doing it or they don't know it's
so obvious
yeah and it's i i'm going to start
calling people out we have to start
calling these people
we have to start we have to bring them
into the car all the movements
um and whether they have testes
or ovaries um yeah but
it's the i don't like it and i if you do
it stop doing it
you heard it and you can take that to
the bank that's how i end the segment
you can take that to the bank moving on
um i have a
non-doc watch this show your honor
brian cranston yeah it's actually the
first episode kind of annoyed me
the second episode it's getting good
your honor great
if you're bored it's like really
tense everything is very
is this gonna happen is this gonna
happen oh [ __ ] did they find
the inhaler did they find the it's um
very
uh uh attention grabbing okay like 24 or
something
yeah but like when they go well they
don't go to commercial but the every
scene could be like dude
everything is very important and yeah it
could be the end of
well i was trouble in the morning
um the i someone made me watch this
flight attendant show on hbo with
kel kelly cuoco
it was like i don't know what's going on
hbo you have the undoing on one hand
which is very good
it's on max well the undoing was on hbo
max
hp but it was produced by the hbo
by hbo this is like beautiful i know
it's a very
scott galloway the guy who's on the
podcast pivot
made of really good observation so hbo
max only has 12 million subscribers
okay but i can't that's what it has a
hundred million
oh um so they
basically took an amazing asset which is
hbo
right and [ __ ] it up they found and
made it into this like
everything everything and nothing they
made like hbo
the brand is and also hbo there's a
metric in hollywood
how much they have to spend per emmy
meaning take your entire yearly budget
yeah and divide it by the number of
emmys okay hbo was 75 million dollars an
emmy
netflix is like hundred and seventy-five
million dollars like they had the lowest
uh output to emmy thing right um so is
hbo max
cinemax and hbo cinemax is not involved
okay
which again is like they don't call it
that then
they should have just called it
something else something that did not
what i will
think is gonna do well for them is
putting all the warner brothers movies
out wonder woman yeah
that's gonna be a street sweep and all
those actors are mad
and chris nolan's mad and all these
people because they are profit
they they were profit participants
meaning they were getting part of the
box office
they're just gonna it's gonna be a
litigation nightmare
and they're going to get the [ __ ] suit
out of them by all these people
and you don't they had to
they they don't if they release this
thing
on if you're the rock or somebody
and you have ten percent of the movie
you're not getting
you can't right you're not gonna get and
anything they do do
you just go well how did you get to that
number how did you know what this was
gonna make
this could be that i they could make a
legal case that it
they have to pay them like it's the
highest
uh grossing movie of all time or
something close to it like because it's
gonna just prove it yeah exactly
they can't disprove it it's so uh yeah
with points now points are useless
yes apparently gal gadot and the warner
the the
the um the wonder woman people
i'm sure her patty jenkins the director
and wig all had points right
yeah wiggs the villain which would be
awesome um
and apparently they they just had to
give them
like they had to give gal gadot like 10
million but like we don't
yeah like but how'd they get to ten but
they have good comps
i mean they have they have comps i'm
assuming
uh they're [ __ ] they don't [ __ ]
okay i'm doing a black sketch show how
well do you think it's going to be no no
no no but like you've already but
i'm saying that's the no no but what i'm
saying is i'm doing it's
2003 i'm doing a black sketch show what
how well do you think it's going to do
pretty well yeah of course right what
are their cops
reno911 [ __ ]
we did we beat all of them so if there's
always the potential to
out that's what they can argue right and
that's what that's
legally warner brothers is [ __ ] in
that way and
as far as i'm concerned is my guess
there was a bunch of articles last week
i'm surprised we didn't talk about it
surprise um also kayla cuoco
was a three mics fan so of course she
wanted me to write
for the the um airplane the airplane
airplane the movie
you know here's the thing about the
airplane the movie it the
the tone my friend me
it was like watching scrubs meet suits
meet psych
like and i don't really like any of
those shows no offense i'm sure the
story is interesting but the music it's
so dated feeling not to [ __ ] on it but
it was just it was so
like not hbo feeling yeah it was just a
different thing
and everyone liked wacky it was wacky it
was
it was like a like a lot of soap opera
music
uh wow so i regret not writing on it
said republican meal um so yeah i don't
know it just
gets confusing when the undoing comes
out and then that comes out was the
undoing good
it was [ __ ] amazing all right i'll
watch it i didn't watch it you have to
watch i watched the first season of all
the ladies
the sweaters that the lady sweater's in
trouble excuse me
uh the one pretty little
liars little fires everywhere no no
that's hulu
wires pretty oh big little lies big
little lies damn it
white ladies and sweaters white ladies
and gentlemen
did you like it did you like that i did
like it i mean i liked the style
i thought over every once in a while
it's fun to watch white
white rich white people be
like rich and white rich kind of just be
rich and white it's just like it's nice
you you got to watch them doing you're
like i will no i i just didn't know
i couldn't get a sense of whether it was
good or not it was really good okay good
it's entertaining enough to watch it um
now
yes we're moving on
yes we're doing emails
[Music]
i received two tips
about the how spicy do you want to do it
with your lover
okay the questionnaire yes one of them
is spicer.com
you can go and there's the questionnaire
there oh
and one is mojo upgrade
dot com i'm assuming they're dot com go
on spicer go on spicer
this is from sean spicer of course the
president's friend
ooh just look up spicer
sex app oh it's an app ah [ __ ] all right
go on the other one
spicer is an app i'm not
oh you say you were you what your likes
and stuff and you get matches
oh you do it with you no you do you and
your partner
um mojo upgrade
uh answer questions on what you want
this this is some
2002 [ __ ] um go up well
answer questions on what you want your
partner answers questions of what they
want we'll show you
where you both match that's interesting
because they don't they don't out you
yeah yeah that's nice they don't go like
you know that's nice
you know what she wanted to do you know
what this wild [ __ ] wanted to do
take pictures watch porn together nah
yup oh they went with knobs
no oh they're pretty cool yup is way
worse
um
really trying to be cool but yep to
these sounds really strange
yep is like okey dokey uh
have partner strip or give me a lap
dance that i gotta say
it would be a nightmare don't
just look dude don't do that don't make
this don't make me
judge you as a performer
do you know what i mean like that's why
i don't like too much dirty talk because
it's bad writing
most of it you like you like that you
dirty who are just like what do you
you should work you got to take a class
no but most of it it could just be i
was wondering i was like lick my balls i
was like oh
no honey no i can't lick my
balls what uh so mojo upgrade and spicer
of course is an app
so so there's we're helping goodbye
you've got
ma'am neil and bianca
look at the video this guy looks real
quick he looks like uh
he looks like cheech he looks like
cheech's son
um this guy looks
13 and 50.
um this guy
he looks like cheech right does he look
like cheech or chong
he looks more like you know i'm so
[ __ ] racist he looks like
uh carlos santana is what he looks like
he looks like
carlos santana which latino when he went
to work with bob marley for three months
i was like hey man we did some pretty
cool stuff um
carlos santana of course also i made him
sound like the stoner from the simpsons
e man hey bro hey little dude
um hit it well hey binky and neil what's
good
got a question for you about comedy
writing neil you always say whoever
writes the most
uh is the best hey and i believe you got
a question about performing though how
does that relate to writing
uh if you're gonna break it down into a
binary witch maybe it's not
um how does performance come in i see a
lot of really great performers that i
personally don't think their jokes are
very good i see a lot of really great
joke
writers whose performance is more
understated how does that relate to each
other binky you're a stand-up sommelier
tell me what you think
love the show appreciate it i love that
this guy
he can almost get it from you he can
almost get it is that your type
you gotta clean up the i mean this is a
[ __ ] if this guy doesn't live in the
bay
i don't know [ __ ] anything he's in
seattle i don't know jack [ __ ]
if i if this guy doesn't live he's also
black he made him latino he's half black
how do you know i can tell uh
clearly he's also half latino you don't
look like you
clearly carlos rasta san
san ra santana rasta uh
uh look at that right there he's he
loves a
terrible he looks on a cliff yeah anyhow
anyways um send good look hit her up
slide slide slide slide slide slide um
uh he mentioned kevin hart and ellen
as his ellen being a good writer he in
the
even in the written one he mentioned
kevin hart as a great performer
and not good writer and ellen as a
good writer wink um
neil show them the words um
uh and not a good performer uh but
that what he's mistaking is energy
yeah for because quality performer
ellen's a [ __ ] great performer
you wouldn't she doesn't run around
she's not yelling but as i pointed out
before
ellen has a perfect comedy pitch
the likes of which you cannot recreate
no one's ever had it so what about kevin
kevin is a
good performer
but i would argue
kevin's jokes vary some some of kevin's
jokes are well written and some
are not um he would say that i bet
yeah um so i mean i don't i don't know a
comic who thinks every joke
they write is great no so how do you
well the mirror sorry my my bigger point
was
the once you can combine the two you're
a hall of famer
yeah if you can write a bunch of jokes
you're alex baze who writes for seth
who's like the best to me the best
joke right in the world the best just
pound for like
you need a joke you're doing a monologue
in five minutes i'll write you
he wrote the joke for seth
um trump says he has a great
relationship with the blacks uh
i'm assuming the blacks is a white
family
yeah um he wrote for seth yeah
uh and he wrote
uh that for tina and amy uh
like a uh 19 year old model's
warm vagina please welcome leonardo
dicaprio
so but he just doesn't he's not a
gregarious guy he doesn't want to
perform right um
so he makes i don't know what he makes
about 500 a year
writing jokes for people um great life
so
but if you're if you're
dave if you're chris at one point was a
great writer and not a great performer
he became a great performer
uh if you're ellen if you're the hall of
fame
tash doesn't move daniel tosh doesn't
[ __ ] move yeah he doesn't it's
amazing he doesn't
literally doesn't touch the mic
and is can make a room explode it's like
[ __ ]
so it's not always running around
and screaming
sometimes it is if it calls for it right
but how does how do you work on
your performance oh you have to give
yourself
uh pavlok
you have to pavlock yourself basically
you have to do things
that chris set up a microphone
and mirrors in his house before bringing
the pain
so he could do it yeah for himself
uh burr picks a different thing
every special that he wants to do that
sometimes writing something is
performing
you have to that's a real outside-in
thing where you have to go
what am i not doing enough of let me do
that
seinfeld is on tim ferriss's podcast
this week
i guess last week and it's the best one
of the best interviews he's ever done
because he really [ __ ] gets into his
process and not
i told him like you're
i referred to simon one time and kind of
didn't hurt his feelings but i go
you're derek jeter you've been around so
long
i don't even know if you're good i just
know
that no no but my point was you're tom
brady is tom brady a great quarterback
i don't [ __ ] even know he's famous he
but like
where is he on the thing that's what
cyber is so seinfeld so
been around for so long like his fame
eclipses his
everything else all you know is he's
like a staple
the problem is when you're so famous
people will laugh at you
no matter what to a point to a point
yeah but i've seen people pop into the
store
dude what seven minutes yes do what
dave will sing the [ __ ] transformers
theme song for 10 minutes and people are
doing
a standing ovation uh which i've seen
yeah it's very weird i was like what
though
um but i do think there is
a lot of leeway when you are so famous
because people are just like somewhat
it's
sometimes that's true and sometimes it's
not like
me and seville did spots one night at
the improv we both kind of ate it
and and i got off
and i was like do you ever feel like you
can't
live up to your intro and he go because
i
i like whatever i felt that about myself
sometimes
and he's like oh yeah i just thought
that
um and he said but then i was like no
get that it's fun just the best
so but he breaks everything down and and
what i'm saying and i told him i was
like as imperious and superior as you
are
you also [ __ ] crush so
i hear a lot of younger comics [ __ ] on
jerry and it's like
really follow him yeah go somewhere and
follow him
and see how much you [ __ ] on him see how
like see how tough you are
when you're when you're uh when you're
thinking about your set and over you can
barely hear yourself think
over the laughs he's getting and not
with hacky stuff
like good [ __ ] quality bits he became
a better performer
in the last the his last netflix was
like
what was that doc he did where he
was really doing something yeah comedian
yeah you're just called he's great
yeah yeah um that was good yeah we see
him
with the look of terror in his eyes
before he goes on
terror um but that so you gotta
do both basically if you can do both
your
if you can do both your um
hall of famer if you can write
incredibly well
your you got to be able
you got to do it a lot like tina's
probably a better writer than performer
right um and she's known more as a
writer
uh that's the thing that i have to deal
with is like all right how do we
let's spruce it up a little bit there
buddy like i can write the jokes
obviously it's like well what
so get to the people that write that you
write for
that's embarrassing it's look i'm a
i'm i have my own you don't know what
i'm carrying
goodbye you've got mail hi neyland
bianca donkdunk
li lscnr uh writing in for the first
time my
friend's brother has a half dozen kids
he's mormon
he and his wife went to africa a while
ago to dig a well or
build huts or something charitable like
that build huts is a little racist
uh anyhow they figured uh that the best
way to really help would be to adopt
a kid and bring him back to be being
american now they have five
white kids and the one adopted black son
there's something that's been kind of
bugging me and i wanted to ask your
opinion
for halloween they dressed their black
son up as mr t
um they posted pics bianca shaking her
head
they posted pics and videos of him in
costume saying i pity the fool another
year they dressed him up as samuel
jackson and made videos of of him saying
what
of him saying say what again um the
other kids
dress up as disney princesses captain
america
uh fireman minecraft characters etc so
my question is
is this racist or am i being an [ __ ]
for thinking that they are
um it seems messed up because i can't
believe that these costumes were the
sun's idea
i don't think kids his age have ever
heard of mr d let alone
like him enough to want to dress up like
him i also doubt the young kids are
watching pulp fiction idolizing jules
winfield
uh his parents are dressing him up as
stereotypes and not even positive ones
he could have been obama mlk and even uh
black panther
if we're doing superheroes but instead
of a powerful black role model they
dress them up as someone with a funny
catchphrase
uh is their behavior studios i think it
is
uh i'm curious to know what you guys
think
i'm so sad that's real
well i could've been worse he could have
the white kids dress up
like like mr t i actually that is kind
of funny
in blackface wouldn't be that much but
what i'm saying is
you can dress up there's a bad there's a
there's a worse version white mr t is
not anything
i'm just saying you can dress up as a
black person without blackface believe
it or
not white jewels is not anything but who
it's [ __ ] halloween i mean yes
well technically people dress up as
penises yeah ovaries testies
uh no i think you can be i think there's
a way it's
preferable if you're going to dress up
as a i believe if they dress up as a
penis
it is racially correct no
white person no black eyes dressing up
like a white dick
oh being funny though that's funny a
tiny like tiny just perfect
uh just i don't know
i don't that's it's racist technically
it's just more ignorant and just like
guys
it's just like it's like he's a
accessory even though people do dress
kids up and
make them say cutesy things and so we
can all laugh so that's
that is just a thing regardless of race
yeah
uh but that's why i'm kind of like i
can't this may be above my pay grade i
don't and i don't say that
um i do i don't think i've ever said
that i know you've
never can't say i do think though
that's that might not be the greatest
thing to do to the kid
he's already i'm assuming they're in
utah
mormon well they're somewhere they're
somewhere
in a white community i don't know at
some point he's going to get othered
and feel like damn i'm the only black
kid in
this situation i bet that's happened
already let's assume it's happened but
maybe at the airport and i brought him
back
uh but something i mean he seems young
so let's just say it's uh
it says five yeah yeah so let's just say
something in the future where he does
actually remember i don't know you do
think back and wonder
oh that was a little
like it's not an accident i mean i was a
bum every year
and by bum yeah i would call myself a
bum
right and i would put coal on my face
because bums
are dirty right hobo bum i it was never
a homosexual it was all hobo or bubble
yeah hobo oh it was hilarious yes
uh but yes i don't know it just feels
a little maybe tone deaf i wonder
i yeah i think you're slicing it thin
here i don't
really i think it should be up to the
kid what he wants to be he's five
right but i don't i think i don't think
that they're assigning the white kids
costumes
no of course they're of course they're
assigning him mr t
yes so what i'm saying is let him decide
what he wants to be
right how am i supposed to but he's got
to be a black person he cannot be a
white character wait how am i slicing
that's my only rule
uh because i feel like i'm taking some
huge no i don't know
i'm just i i think the issue to me the
big issue is let him decide what he
wants to
what what he wants to be um
and then that's on the one hand and then
the other hand i think ah they adopted
the kid let him have some fun
i'm kidding uh and then the other thing
i think it's costume slavery
i do i do think this writer should
bring it up be like it's a little it's
interesting you're
like don't scold but just i would i
would have questions
i was around well yeah i would i would
give him one of those like hey walk me
through your psychology here
hey just i was just thinking
great costume idea right walk through it
a walk me through it would be really
good i had a good
thought that i don't know what to do
with tell us your good thought
um there uh
there's a there's this podcast called
intelligence squared which is
great [ __ ] awesome it's just two p
it's teams debating
issues and you have to and then they
take they
ask the audience beforehand and then
they ask them after the argument
whose side they're on right and whoever
converts the most people's the winner
anyhow because of covet they do them
that are they don't do the voting part
but it was eric michael dyson and uh or
michael eric dyson
eric michael michael eric and um and
uh john i want to say wart
it's a another black intellectual who
people
think is more uh conservative
um john mcwhorter um he's not he's just
a
old-school liberal but eric michael
dyson brought up a thing beyonce said
which is
um people
beyonce apparently said when you bring
up racism
when you're against racism people think
you're when you challenge racism
people think you're challenging america
right right
but i which made me think that
black people especially are
in a relationship
with an abusive narcissist what
america and i would say it's codependent
but it's like they [ __ ] can't go
anywhere
so how do you how do you
deal with a abusive narcissist and then
i was like
maybe a compliment sandwich would work
where you go like
america you're great stop hitting me
but you're amazing so that's my
i don't know how to roll that out right
large
but it is that's what it is it is you
can only
you can't criticize america you can't
criticize white america directly
far too fragile yeah you have to be like
look everybody knows the best country on
earth
right and given my i would
this is a if i have to be oppressed this
is the place
had one thought
don't kill me you can i get it
you can kill me try not to
don't ever change yeah it's that's kind
of why
and i don't know how you do that policy
why that's what i was saying last week
about persuasion and
like martin luther king going like bye
to dream right
hey just a dream and you pointed out
that he was murdered which is true
what i wish i'd pointed out was but he
also got the voting rights pac
acts passed and the civil rights bill
passed
he got a ton of [ __ ] pass so martin
luther king
and the mountaintop they're both true
do you know what i mean no of course i
understand why
there was a divide between him and you
know malcolm x's style and
kind of there there was a divide of how
to go about this thing that
no one knows how to go about yeah you
know um
but i i do think you fatigue
on the play nice after a while
you're just like oh of course okay so
just of course everybody yesterday
frederick douglass
had to just go around for 10 years
talking about how slavery was wrong
before they were finally
in the 1850s so this is before
any he what he escaped and basically
became like a
comic more or less he was just on the
road to the road
and uh like i was saying last week a lot
of uh america is like i can't believe i
have to say that a lot of
social change is i can't believe i have
to say this
and it's
as someone who has to deal with very
little
actual oppression but someone who wants
people to like
have less kids eat less meat and [ __ ]
like that i can't believe i have to say
hey man you know it's bad for the
you know this is we're raising the
temperature of the air then we're
suffocating ourselves right
it's exhausting it's the fact that i
have to say that
and that it's controversial is so
[ __ ] insane
yeah and but i can't be like [ __ ] you
you can't you can't start biting people
and burn the house down
so i don't know how we got there i say
put the kid next year
in a uh i think if you're gonna go out
as a black icon do it big and go out
as uh goodbye tyrone bagum's the
crackhead
you've got mayonnaise lstner my wife and
i have been
together off and on since we were 20
we're 40 now when we met we were just
kids who partied and did drugs together
and had silly goose times remember that
yay
um we've obviously changed over the
years after someone died a few years ago
my wife went deep into new age
spirituality
all of it crystals energy work astrology
[ __ ] kill me the whole [ __ ] in
shaboodle
i'm i'm an agnostic skeptic who finds
all that stuff incredibly cringy and
ridiculous
if not an outright scam and i have a
hard time keeping that opinion of myself
if it comes up
we've gotten some pretty big fights
about it because despite her being an
otherwise smart and successful woman i
have
a hard time respecting her opinions due
to some of the beliefs that inform them
she can give me good advice and then
ruin them by tying it to where jupiter
is at the moment or whatever the [ __ ]
uh we did ayahuasca together again the
best
i don't know that should have solved all
your problems and while i did have a
profound personal experience myself none
of this dynamic has really changed in
the interim
we get along okay day to day but i can't
help but wonder if she'd be happier with
someone who
connects more on that specific kind of
level we have kids and are pretty
financially dependent on each other
so just waking uh so just walking over
this
away so just walking away over this
seems improbable
uh what are your thoughts on surviving
in a cross-spiritual relationship
sometimes feel like a bernie bro married
into mega
how can i good ideas on both sides
something i mostly see is nonsense
this is you this is your hail dog
uh all right dog um i would
say is there a way
to actively agree on not talking about
that [ __ ]
like can we compartmentalize it out
because
it's like religion almost like we can
not talk about religion
all my grandmothers are religious yeah
some of my family's really just
never do we ever talk about god so i
wonder if we could
keep like feed the bonds that we do have
and just really kind of not talk about
it you know
is there a way could you be in a
relationship with someone
that let's just make it like a q anon
that's actually really [ __ ] up it's
something less something more innocuous
yeah yeah they're all they all get
if they're innocuous they're not a
problem well crystals and [ __ ] is
inaudible
but to his point if she has good advice
and then you hear
what her logic is you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah
if someone does it gets on a calculator
and goes six and then they tell you it's
you know 12. yeah and and and then
they go six plus six is twelve how'd you
find that out
i prayed it's like you'd be like oh [ __ ]
i'm not no we can't
i mean i don't i i wouldn't i think that
just
a firewall yeah just don't talk about it
yeah i don't care how you got to that
answer
don't show your work yes do not
show your work or you fail yes keep it
in your pants
i think you just have to accept that you
guys
fundamentally disagree yeah the problem
is when and i had this with
a friend who kept sending me pandemic
and all this
bill gates of hell [ __ ] and i just said
look man
don't send me this i i don't want to
talk about this
she kept sending me and i passed out i
was like
we fundament i fundamentally disagree
with everything you've sent me
i've read it all i researched it all i
respect you enough to research it it is
nonsense i've asked you to stop you have
to stop or else
i'm gonna start looking at you different
you know just stop i can
get past this but just [ __ ] off with
this [ __ ] and then it was fine how'd she
take it
well she the reason what sent me off she
sent me a candace owens clip
and she was like she's actually you
probably don't like that
and i was like she's a bad [ __ ] and she
is
this person is of the uh
caucasian the caucus islands and so i
was like
dude [ __ ] off like i cannot stop stop
i and i think the problem is person with
white skin
and ovaries cheesy person with ovaries
um i what i realized is that she
actually wanted to
somehow convince me because she
respected me
and she was like i just i respect your
opinion yeah and i agree with a lot of
what you say
and the fact i think the what the meat
and potatoes is you aren't agreeing with
this thing i believe in yeah
so i kind of which is a problem that's a
problem i need this
sign the contract and so i wonder if
they can
understand that they just disagree or
it's like
a thorn in maybe her side that he's just
like scoffs at this [ __ ] you know i
wonder if they can
firewall it i got you got a firewall do
you see that
yeah and you just crystals get them out
or
put them on the roof just give her a
woman you are a sphere
where are you in this i'm a padre
for i am a person with white skin
with testes testes and
padre and a padre coat
i've had a similar experience and i
can't it's just at a certain point
you're like
i don't even even i've
i've dated a woman who was super into
bernie
and it just got to the point where i was
like i think you're naive about what's
possible
yeah i don't think that what you're what
you want is wrong
no yeah i just think that the idea that
it's going to happen in america in the
next
generation is uh silly
and once that happens it doesn't like
end it but it's
you just kind of like i don't know what
to do
what what do you want me to do i just
think you're really wrong and you if you
dedicate
time to it i think it's silly
um i'm a spirit i'm a skeptic
i'm a spirit padre who's i'm a skeptical
do you like
are you skeptical much um are you
into crystals no i think
the idea of crystals is uh
bananas it's plantains it's beyond
bananas
it's a step past platadome
you know it's crazy though i'm not into
crystals but
my friend has this mat from japan
and it's a bunch of crushed up amethyst
anything you're in the crystals i'm not
into this at all yeah at
all i it's rocks right now
no no no no i i pulled some people that
were listening
i think she's interested
um so i was i was really feeling
terrible i was getting sick
he was like come lay on my crystal mat
and you'll feel better and i was like
dude no chance like it's just i
know when i'm getting sick i know so
that's the such a
he's he wants to [ __ ] you no no he
didn't want to [ __ ] me you guys
you know i got a crystal ball he did and
i don't offer it to a lot of people
he didn't want to [ __ ] me anyway so i
laid in his crystal mat
not sick well then it then there it is
so there it is i did a study i polled
some people too that's it
they're all named binkerton empirical
what
goodbye you've got the mail hey nalen
banks
where do you guys stand with people
calling their significant others
partners versus girlfriend slash
boyfriend
i'm personally on the fence with it
though i've recently changed that to a
non-monogamous relationship style
uh i've changed to a nominal
relationship style
intend to date two women at a time i bet
this guy has a crystal mat
um i like the term partner because for
some reason
saying my girlfriend feels singular
girlfriends for some reason sounds
misogynistic but partners work for me in
this case
it's intriguing to me when a monog when
monogamous people use it
but i do hear it more often
would you care if you had a significant
other who wanted to use that
terminology how neolabs what
bank slit tanks
i don't
i think girlfriend and boyfriend is
of incredibly corny i think it's so
corny it's like i just picture like
that picture of like people walking on
the street with their hand in each
other's jean pocket
butt slot yeah it's just like my
girlfriend
i'm with her yeah he's with me i i think
it's just not for adults but it's the
name i mean whatever
it's what's happening but that do you
say it's my girlfriend
yeah yes you say that's my babe no
i don't but i don't like
i i partner's better i don't like any i
really don't
like to say boyfriend i know but that's
because it's cool no [ __ ]
cringe yeah yeah it's just it's the word
then again when i live when i if i speak
other language if i'm speaking another
language
i just whatever it's the term like in
german you just say friend
so that's my friend but they conjugate
for girl and boy
it's like oh yeah that's my friend you
just have to use it correctly but it's
the same word
so i don't know but girlfriend i don't
like saying boyfriend though
it feels like i'm 15. yeah it feels like
you work for
it it just feels like a weird indenture
yeah
it feels like but i'm weird so i think
a lot of people do like saying boyfriend
i i'm weird i don't like i'm commitment
phobic so
i don't love it but i don't i don't i
don't i don't like it
not only do i not like it but i don't
know like partner sounds gay to me
so i sound like a lesbian if i'm like
yeah but it's a partner if they're
a person with ovaries and you're a
person with testes and you call them
your partner
it's like do you guys have a law firm i
don't know well no that's what you run
against but
it's better than boyfriend partner
yes my partner how about partner this
morning
that's my partner what a partner
um yeah i'd say girlfriend and boyfriend
hopefully will end in my lifetime that's
what should we call them partner
um follow me on twitter would love to
wow would love to
what would you love to do goodbye i have
a meal with her
oh is she cooking lay on my crystal mac
you've got mail banks hey neil and banks
r c and l e hello hello elastini are
hello neil and bjork i don't
i really do not like how my voice sounds
recorded
uh but i had a question discussion to
submit i want
to preface the fact that i'm not
actively thinking sexually of neil nor
attracted
i'm a dick but i wouldn't i this is so
unnecessary
no you've no no uh i had a random
dream i had a random dream that you and
a couple comedians were hanging out
uh watching a movie with other friends
and i was there would never happen i
know
you approached me to have a sex contract
including two other comedians
and i said i'm not interested in the
other two but i'd consider a contract
with you alarm went off woke up didn't
get played out
so with that in mind would you have
create
sex contracts with people bianca same i
am
honestly thought not a bad option or
thing to do
uh you seem to be very black and white
about everything else so maybe i mean
he's already said he was first of all
co-wrote a sketch called love contract
i'm 15 years ago
yeah um want to schedule it
want minimums
i want questionnaires i hate it i want
to systematize it you do you do
and um this is also kind of what you
thought was happening when we were on
ayahuasca where you thought
yeah i was like this is like my rock
we're trying to set up a contract
okay you talk to these [ __ ] about a
contract but we need to make it
officially
um that's what i mean when i say i want
to make it official they go marry me oh
no i want to set up a sex contract
well you do like contracts i like i
think a marriage is a contract
i think that in some ways
people there's a part of me that thinks
people will be better off dating
for six months and then that's the end
no matter what
what why that's just what i think it is
very
like it then you re-up
you wait a year what you wait a year
for what reason you see
see if it sticks meliophilia see if it
sticks because i
have some romantic moments i have to
think that a lot of i think a lot of
marriages
are you have this magical feeling with
somebody
and then it dissipates but you get
married because you're like but we had
the feeling
it's like we were on we both got a ring
together living off steam yeah you're
going off steam and it's like we went to
it's like we won a championship
so i i got to be friends i got to stay
friends with
him or her because like we had we had a
magical thing
for one moment you're just trying to
commemorate this feeling you used to
have impossible
impossible okay they did that okay
um so yes contract yes systematized yes
to six month marriages
marriage is nothing more than um
uh sentimentality
of bygone types goodbye yo you've got
mail your weed talk is so cringy listen
to you talk about how
hooping and we don't mix sounds so
hollow
been hooping since i was a kid been
hooping and smoking for 10 plus years
smoked before and after it's no biggie
you heard blake say it wasn't a big deal
just take the
l and accept that it works for some
basketball moves at a fast pace and yet
you need to slow down and play in
control
without overthinking otherwise you look
like russell westbrook out there
whipping shots off the glass
weed helps also i doubt the hoopers who
smoke and hoop get as high as you
consistency breeds a higher tolerance
plus smoking after hooping is the mf
best not to mention it's a much better
method for recovery compared to the
opioids provides
for most athletes provided for most
athletes
but i'm a rando that you have no reason
to trust you
you said it bud uh you should check out
all the smoke podcasts if you hadn't
especially the al harrington episode
sorry for the long letter fyi was longer
been hate listening since day one
talk about cringy yeah all right uh
okay okay so this is so his example of
why hooping is good for you is al
harrington
who who's what exactly okay al
harrington who
maybe almost was an alternate on the
all-star team once
uh versus if you don't smoke weed you're
gonna be russell westbrook
the last guy to average a triple
triple-double two seasons in a row
so his examples are over here
al harrington and over here over here
uh uh uh russell westbrook a hall of
famer
um and he's saying that he's cute
yeah uh he's rich too oh he got the
blake hey russell so so russell
westbrook is uh
is his example of why you shouldn't
smoke weed
um and i took an l apparently i have a
question
who says hooping people saying they're
like i'm hooping today
later i'm hoping still
it sounds so like 90s sprite cards i
mean there's just not a lot of you're
not wrong but
you know hooping what kind of hoop
uh um so
you don't so al harrington is an example
of a guy that you should smoke weed
apparently
and if you're al harrington you can
average what did al harrington average
there well
um uh six
nine goddamn they're all monsters 13.5
points a game you can average
if you're al harrington now type in
russell westbrook career average
uh you can average uh career
uh you can average uh 23 points a game
so that's a ten point difference from
what i can tell
oh and by the way russell westbrook his
whatever that's because he his first two
seasons didn't score enough
um so this guy
apparently i took an l by saying that
you should smoke
the only difference the only
uh evolution i've had on this
is if you another guy
suggested seth uh seth rogen smokes all
the time and is it
what then he's great okay but how would
he be if he didn't
like you don't know how well i heard it
would be if he didn't but also
rogan's didn't smoke weed for a very
long time like
absolutely didn't smoke and then he
spoke so it's like i don't know this is
right but i don't
it's not even yeah it's like i know he's
been great
it's it's it's in general is it good or
i don't i would prefer a league where
everyone's not high
again i think even this guy would say
that i don't know so if that
i don't think he'd say am i actively
taking an l um
what i have come around to is a buddy of
mine who i'm i think we should have on
the show
named carl hart who has a book coming
out
uh called drug use for adults
um he
he basically advocates
that adults should use drugs and and the
weed test is
people that don't smoke weed if they
smoke weed can't do [ __ ]
people that do that are habitual users
which is what this guy's getting at
don't uh their skills don't uh
depreciate
in the thing they're doing so again i
don't think lebron again
i don't think any hall of famer in the
nba is regularly smoke weed would they
have been better
i would argue probably not but who knows
again that's me taking it now um neil
just take the l
and uh and so
so carl hart's book okay he says
i do heroin sometimes whoa i do cocaine
sometimes
and i do molly sometimes here's the rub
he is a he's a black man
and he's the head of the the uh
neuropsychology department at columbia
university
wow i literally read it like holy [ __ ]
what is he getting from that what is he
what he's saying is
he's advocating just well his name's
carl hart
the book's not out yet um
he's cute is he cute for you yeah hey
carl
um i don't know i don't love dreads now
you know yeah i hear you
uh drug use for grown-ups coming out
january 12th so
he's saying that there's so much
misinformation
that you can't even we don't even really
know what we know what drugs are like in
a
like fentanyl has been around since
1960. yeah
the problem is combinations uh
most heroin overdoses are because of
uh another is a lot of it's alcohol
um and there are things that uh
deplete your lung nut capacity but your
lung function
that's that can be a side effect for
certain people
if it is then don't do the [ __ ] drug
like or
if you have a bad heart if you have that
we don't take into consideration
comorbidities for what or or uh
coincidental use of another drug or
alcohol or whatever
when we hear stories of people dying but
what is he getting from
doing here he's getting he's it's
[ __ ] euphoric
okay and it's just he doesn't get
addicted
he in his first book he does studies
with crap
he literally colombia did studies with
weed with crack
crack or cocaine crack come in
do crack necessary crack
yeah why not no just keep don't look at
it
never study what it does to people no no
no no i'm just saying that
there's just some like weed cocaine like
crack is
a mix of other substances i'm like
you know it's just a different cocaine
recipe
yeah but it's to me it's the ultimate
cocaine recipe it's just
for the holidays no it's just me what
he's saying is
let's address these things like adults
they exist
it's a massive issue we throw away
billions of dollars a year uh his
like put in uh will 2019
heroin overdoses america
you got to walk through guys again the
next thing you know you're yelling about
the set
uh okay opioid
overdose draits rates
thank you um
and uh
specific category
that one figure two on the right will
click on the right thank you buddy
okay so green yeah
green is antidepressants no heroin
okay so heroin 14 000 heroin overdoses
now do
heroin overdoses portugal
anyhow according to carl yeah 60 heroin
overdoses
what are they doing in portugal it's
legal
so in order to uh
it just handle like an adult you know
people are going to do it
give people an environment where they
can do it weed's legal now
i still don't like weed right
it's this assumption that if something's
legal there's going to be a stampede
gambling's legal not a problem for me
like
and you say what about the people it is
a problem for they need treatment
if they're if they find themselves in
the in the
system of a legal drug um
so that's the only thing with weed is
that
it if you do if you do it regularly you
will not have a depreciation but the
book
the [ __ ] he says in the book is like wow
yeah
like and and he admitted it because he's
like i don't want to be a hypocrite
i don't want to be someone who on the
outside is saying
i uh that i believe that these things
should be legal
but and that adult should be able to do
them the only the way i'll get it done
is by just saying
i do them and i'm the head of
neuropsychology or neurobiology
uh drug use for adults comes out january
12th or for grown-ups
um click that click that
uh there's a review in discover magazine
page turning science book
anyhow it's it's it's crazy and
uh he also points out that at festivals
they will in at british festivals
they'll put
basically like a a printout of
a drug like a molly pill
and um
what's in it if it's deadly if it's any
phen whatever they they test it
but the problem is the cops test it and
they re the way they get it is by
confiscating it
so it's like just [ __ ] let's be
adults about it
right and assume that people are gonna
do it anyway
and by being uh
opaque you're just causing more deaths
yeah like i i i'm not gonna do heroin
like i don't i don't i'm not interested
in heroin
i mean i am interested but i'm not gonna
do it um
so it's it's fascinating so that's again
i've taken so many l's matt barnes
al harrington and uh and
whoever the other dude is and uh matt
barnes al harrington who's the other guy
and oh
no the other guy in all this smoke
they're not a good example
of the league would not be they're like
that's an advertisement for the big
three that's not an advertisement for
the nba
anyhow goodbye
[Laughter]
part one i was initially going to get
your thoughts and advice about dating
people with mental health issues
uh uh after a recent relationship i had
with someone
with an undiagnosed borderline
personality disorder it was the most
crazy and intense thing i've ever
experienced
and i'm now also convinced smallpox
blanket statement
whatever happened to that segment uh
that
folks that uh all cult leaders
suffer from some form of bpd as they get
caught up in their [ __ ] storm and tidal
wave of emotions
since then uh i've been wondering
if for me anyway being well versed in my
own anxiety depression and ocd
uh that to have any strong feelings
towards someone
they need to have some kind of for lack
of a better description brokenness
whether it be bpd anxiety or other
thoughts on dating people with known
mental health issues be it under control
or work in progress
and how it affects things for you um
i thought part two i thought today you
should create a tinderesque dating app
albeit for people who've taken ayahuasca
no
no not enough money
uh i mean this guy's saying
should you date people with mental
health issues
and he's also saying that like he
doesn't
he also they're all cult leaders
but he says he wanted to have any strong
feeling towards someone they need to
actually have some kind of
uh brokenness well i think that's the
thing we talked about before there's
something
there's something romantic about a red
flag
there's something romantic about it oh
yeah yeah i mean there's some
that's
then the question is are red flags all
mental health
are some of them just weird
weird or just like man he likes to [ __ ]
it doesn't mean he has a
or yeah it probably doesn't mean that
mental it can or cannot whatever
um i would also argue that cult leaders
have just narcissistic personality
disorder and not apd
bpd there's like a downside to which is
you turn on people for no [ __ ] reason
i think everyone hates you yeah it's
like the uh pedestal
you know put people pedestalized or
the other one yeah um um
i i don't i don't want to say that you
shouldn't date people with mental health
disorders
i would say that you're raising a level
of difficulty for yourself
and well not for them because they
they're they're already they already
have a high level of difficulty just
know
it's gonna be a high level difficulty
it's also
gonna be more spectacular at points i
bet gonna be
interested it's not gonna be boring yes
it will never be boring it will never be
boring but i think you need to
once you've done it enough you it's you
that starts fatiguing
it's like well it's repetitive as [ __ ]
once you've gone through the cycle
of you hate me no i don't
yes you do no i don't you know what i
thought about it
and you're right you don't hate me and
then a week later
you hate me okay [ __ ] i cannot
do this again
it's just all the the
you're right i'm being [ __ ] up no the
the
personal attacks i'm so sorry for you
you're being manipulative
yeah you're by saying that i'm being
mentally ill that's my mentality i've
had so many of the like
oh you admitted that that one was you
that was kind of your fault
i thought about it no yeah it was your
fault of course
okay of course yeah yeah um
so ah
it's i don't know because then you're
just like well
are they totaled do they have more good
than that how problematic is there
it's like any how manageable is the
problem right
um i also you know try to give a good
old
like not ultimatum but a good i can't
do this if you're gonna keep doing this
at the beginning
when they don't have a lot on you to
spin in their head
to be like and she did this and then
like just
yeah i mean that that'll get you 10 days
it's true that'll give you 10 days a
piece and then it's coming back
it's they can't help it
i mean even if they're in a tree i know
people in treatment programs that will
text me and be like why do you hate me
are you serious okay so what do those
people do
they get treatment they get
they stop smoking weed they they or
they get on the right medicine they get
off the wrong medicine they
have a protocol that they need to follow
and then they just get lazy
or or it just gets repetitive and they
forget to do it and
then next thing you know you [ __ ]
hate them
um yeah um
this will be our final goodbye
you've got mail oh this is mom a little
dude them you recently talked about the
blind date era
i'm from the blind date harem you
[ __ ] and you got a lot uh
and actually my why i met my wife of 20
years on a blind date this got me
thinking of a topic from the 1989 movie
sex lives
um yes another old reference
directed by the great stephen soderbergh
maybe it's overrated maybe it's maybe
it's amazing
um in the in it the characters talk
about how men and women can instantly
know if there's physical attraction to
each other
however the difference between the sexes
is not as
is that as soon as a man sees a woman he
immediately knows he's physically
attracted or not whereas women
have the capacity to actually grow a
physical attraction to a man
once she gets to know much more about
him etc with men
that doesn't seem to ever happen so is
it possible for a man to grow a physical
attraction to a woman
even though he is not instantly
attracted to her in the first place in
my blind date experiences as soon as i
met
up with the woman at the bar or whatever
i immediately
knew if this was going to be uh this is
going to work from a physical attraction
point of view
whereas i've always gotten the sense
from women that they need to more need
more information about you to decide if
they can
become attracted to you um
i don't know if i've said this on the
podcast i believe
when you meet someone from an app
you ever like top gun when they land
you [ __ ] they will not [ __ ] shut
this movie down
um they land on a
on the aircraft carrier if they don't
catch the thing they have to take off
again
i think you should be able to do that
when you meet someone from an app
you just be able to walk past them and
go nope
and keep walking
oh that's so yeah and they can do it
also
and that's then you fly back into the
danger zone you get the [ __ ] off the
aircraft karen back in the danger zone
i believe that
uh
the funny thing is with women when they
learn to be attracted to you
i this is i may have projected this but
obviously
it's the full package for me it's a lot
of personality
plus all this body audio
give me the horse
[Music]
the when a girl and i have been in a
fight and i'm like coming back from the
bathroom
for bed and i'm just in my underwear i
can see how gross they think i am
you know what i mean like if we're
getting along i'm cute
but if we're not getting along it's like
[ __ ] ugh um
i've never like projection but of course
it is but i i'm probably not that wrong
um once you've grown once a guy's grown
on you it's hard to
re-see the gross
when you're getting ready to break up
with somebody no no that's what it is i
mean that's
that's just that's what i'm talking
about it's like a big fight
a big big fight it's like you're balding
in your dicks whatever yeah
yeah yes your dicks whatever
what a damning set what a damning phrase
she didn't even bother with
whatever with with adjectives just
whatever
um if you really want to hurt a guy's
feeling just say your dicks whatever
um okay i don't but
you could never grow attraction never
no no no well she's so generous
does that [ __ ] gonna boing me um
what is funny when someone thinks
they're
hot based on one attribute
i know my hands are is together okay and
like you can just see
them being very very typical mr t voice
who knows i pity the [ __ ]
who knows what i'm doing you don't know
if she's latino or black
okay tanks or blinks um uh
like i know and meanwhile she's gross
but like she's just focusing on one part
of herself and just staying tight
but the thing is that's just of course
gross girls get dudes of course they do
yeah
it's because that's just that that's a
numbers game the thing is a guy
can't grow attracted to a girl but a
guy's bar for attractive women is lower
than
women think it's what bar
there's no bar this is [ __ ]
especially no
there's no bar there's no there's
nothing
right there's just available or not
right
and then so girl is like everything is
like
a touching scene from like powder or
something just
i have grown yeah i love
him well it's another thing that you can
watch and
watch happen to you yeah and it's very
narrative about my feelings can you
believe it
uh uh my feelings but cordon off into
acts
um goodbye you've got anyway i've got a
question probably more for neil but i
always love bianca's take on things i've
been married to a songwriter
going on 15 years and recently he
received an angry email from a past
girlfriend of his regarding a song
he has rewritten and put out into the
world uh
she ha she was really really
changed the locks angry that he had
rewritten a song that was
that was about her the funnier and
perhaps psycho part of this
was the song was actually not written
about her at all but
is about her sister yeah i know who i
married
a [ __ ] dirtbag um there is no bar
ladies there's no bar
uh and the bar is open and i have a
crystal mat
um this opened up a funny conversation
about all the wives girlfriends
flings and made up sirens that have been
immortalized in well-known songs
how many girlfriends got pissed off
because the x inspired a song which
turned out to be a bigger hit
or it was a sexier song uh since i think
a great joke is like a great song in
many ways my questions are below
have you ever had girlfriends get
jealous over certain past jokes about an
ex that
pack a bigger punch in the laugh
department or upset
over new jokes that clearly have nothing
to do with them but
for the joke say for the joke's sake you
say my girlfriend do you ever have to
explain
when getting into a relationship that
whatever is said on a stage or written
is going to be taken with a grain of
salt thanks to the podcast
etc etc
you've dated a comic and uh yeah i
didn't love
that sort of thing um i don't
i'm really i don't like those kind of
displays of
sort of i guess affection or sometimes
in a comic
a comics case they're making fun of you
but they you know they're talking about
you so whatever
yeah that's the thing that i've heard
it's always nice
that i don't of course it's not i don't
think it's
really nice i mean there's certain [ __ ]
where it's never been negative
yeah but it i did leave me out of it
leave me
out leave me out i've had an ex
uh have a tattoo of me but not of me
just of
me of the past the podcast
how do you feel with the old giant so
it's just me little um
never forgive so uh
no it was symbolically of me but it had
a
head and part of my name in it and i did
not like that
at all we were dating and i was like
get stay away man like no well that's
that's
dumb that's just dumb dumb so stupid
i just i don't think i like any another
ex of mine
um his roommate writes for a very big
musician and uh
he and he has roommates go ahead this is
before
okay and uh he was his roommate then he
got big and he's a big writer and he
made a song based on like
our arguments me and his arguments and
he told me that he told
my ex that my ex told me that when were
x's and so
and i listened to the song one i didn't
like the song two all my friends i told
absolutely did not believe me yeah well
they were just like
okay yeah so just it always feels a bit
ego maniac you're never gonna this is
about me
oh yeah no this is actually about me and
like i don't like any of that so i don't
i i don't want any part of this that's
what i mean
i've had
audiences all mine are guys
oh i mean all right well i dated a girl
that i mentioned in three mics i don't
say who it is but
but she broke up with me basically and
then but she's one of my favorite
singers ever
yes so listening to her
album knowing that she rejected me
is like some other it's like a flip side
of this that's like
it was it was stupid of me to even
listen to it but like it would when
you're fly when you're when you're
when you're luxuriating and the pain
okay if she made a song album that was
about your breakup
would you how would you feel about that
i'm not saying she didn't uh uh
if it was insulting i would have been
insulted but if it was like let's just
say it was about it yeah not
i wouldn't that wouldn't bother me but i
have jokes
up like i did a setup where i was like
my girlfriend's asian
and then then girls go like so are you
mad that i'm not asian
that's a and b asian girls are like so
it's because i'm asian so it's like you
[ __ ] you've lost
both you've lost everyone um wait what
are your guys stories
my guy stories are
uh a guy that i went to college with and
i had like a very
that wasn't even tumultuous he was just
a narcissist and i said you're a [ __ ]
narcissist
you said it yeah and then
he wrote and i think
was yeah he's in it where
he basically told the our story
but he made himself me he made himself
the the the the the uh
sympathetic one it was a classic
narcissist oh my god
it was like a [ __ ] classic narcissist
move where it was like
i couldn't when someone told me about he
didn't even tell me
i watched and i was like oh
it was just it's so weird like dude
you're a [ __ ]
maniac yeah um that's really
but it's just what a narcissist does
well you know there's a very popular
movie that i'm not gonna say
that is based on something a guy did to
a girl
and he rewrote it that the girl did it
to him uh
of course that's so that actually did
have me
this one guy dated was terrible he was
terrible
there's a lot of weird stuff i'll like
spare you but he
he just did a lot of weird creepy things
when we were breaking up like
he's like hey i got you flowers and then
put them on my doorstep but
he like clearly just smashed a bottle
and put the flowers in it was like
broken glass everyone was like
okay i don't know what that's all very
weird stuff
um then he sent me a link out of nowhere
and he's like hey
this uh this short uh you inspired me
sure and it was just this girl
coming out of a movie the four scariest
words in the english language you
inspired a short
and so it's him and his girl and he's
coming out of a movie
and she's like god that this the famous
actor in it
is so [ __ ] hot i would [ __ ] this
like she's just filthy mouth tired about
how
badly she wanted to [ __ ] the lead and i
remember one time
i just happened to say a guy on tv he's
like oh yeah he's attractive
no couldn't handle that that's how a guy
hears that like i want to lick his balls
yeah so then i mean she looked
so terrible this character looked she
was such a
[ __ ] idiot rude obnoxious the whole
thing and he was such a nice guy
throughout the whole thing
i think at the end she like falls off a
cliff i was just like
thank you why did you say why did you
take time
why do you do scout locations for that
yeah what i mean people are is that is
that so you think that's a
narcissistic thing i'm this the thing
that i explained we're just a vengeful
i'm going to write down the movie that
the thing happened
maybe it's but it's it's a movie
narcissistic
just a narcissist is the person who is
is a villain and then reshoots it so
he's the victim of a villain
that's what a narcissist does whatever
whatever i need to do to win
this thing come on to explain yeah yeah
um this is the
movie it was basically the movie the
movie
wow are you serious yeah
uh i know the person who wrote that no
you don't
uh not not i know
you know who wrote it yeah the star
wrote it oh this
okay sorry i know someone who helped me
yeah yeah wow
yeah anyhow sorry sorry um
but uh but the movie the thing that i
was in oh yeah it's just so [ __ ]
weird
that's so funny it was just like it was
like
uh it was like oh it was
trigonometry for [ __ ] weird human
manipulation i was like
it was spider-man it was spider-man
spider-man
it was [ __ ] spider-man um and james
blake wrote a song
based on my new show
that is great okay that's nice that's
great and i
just kind of asked him i kind of invited
him to
like hey maybe if you want here's my
here's the script for the new show
if you have now with him and james
listens to the podcast
i may like a new song of his more for it
okay same idea it was free no i it's
very
the other one's going to be free too um
but yeah it's just i but there it's like
a coin toss between these two songs
um so yeah so those are the songs
written or the songs and the jokes but i
there are comics to talk about their
wives that if i were their wives i would
punch them in the face
well i remember a friend at the show
uh rock used to talk about his now
ex-wife in a way that was like well
i think they have to fight now right so
kevin hart's ex-wife has done some
stand-up she's been to the store a few
times
and i remember she said something she's
like he made millions
for years just like on me
like i'm the material which i was kind
of like and then
anyways it was just interesting how i
think it
does regardless just human nature i
think it does feel like that
it does feel like hey you used me
my i was your subject matter yeah but it
isn't like that
it's hard to not hear it so rarely does
someone
a girl say something that will become a
joke
right it's more there's a morphology
categorical behavior where you're like
like it someone had to make it funny
yeah
yeah but i understand that it feels like
that it feels very much like you made
millions
saying yeah but i even like if dave
talks about like dave do
this joke about chip people go are you
chip and i'd be like no this is a
[ __ ] chip
like it's just a white scenario some
scenario with a white person it's not
like
and it you're the only white person so
you're it
uh people are simple that's my point
let's do it we did it we don't have to
take
it's there's [ __ ] here and we don't have
to take it nope
goodbye happy holidays everybody
[Music]
[Music]